Hello everybody! This is your last week of reruns before we get back to breaking down episodes from season 9. Yes! We're so excited! This week we are rerunning Baby Shower. Yeah, and I recently came across an awesome quote from Melora Harden about this episode that I wanted to read. Are you ready for this? Angela, I sent you this message and we were both like, this is so Melora. This is so badass Melora. Okay, here it is. She said, quote, Greg and his wife Suzanne had me and my husband over for brunch along with Steve and Nancy Carell and their two kids. My daughter Piper was just a few months old
大家好！这是重播的最后一周，之后我们将回归分解第九季的剧集。是的！我们太兴奋了！这周我们重播的是《迎婴派对》。是的，我最近偶然看到梅洛拉·哈登（Melora Harden）关于这一集的一段精彩引言，我想读给大家听。你们准备好了吗？安吉拉，我把这条信息发给了你，我们俩当时都觉得，这太有梅洛拉的风格了。这太有梅洛拉那股飒爽劲了。好吧，内容是这样的。她说，引用一下：“格雷格和他的妻子苏珊邀请我和我丈夫去吃早午餐，同行的还有史蒂夫和南希·卡瑞尔夫妇以及他们的两个孩子。我的女儿派珀当时才几个月大
at the time. We all sat down at the table and she was hungry, so I just pulled my shirt down and breastfed her because I was very committed to this idea that I don't really like putting a thing over my baby's head when they're breastfeeding. I also feel like we live in a country where people can have a gun rack in the back of their car but you can't breastfeed your baby in public when that's what your boobs are for." She went on to say that this might have inspired a scene in the baby shower episode. And I was like, oh yes, I remember shooting something where she's nursing, but I don't think it ended up in the episode.
当时。我们都在桌子旁坐下，她饿了，所以我直接把衬衫拉下来喂她母乳，因为我非常坚信这样一个观点：我其实不太喜欢在宝宝喝母乳时往她们头上罩个什么东西。我也觉得，我们生活在这样一个国家：人们的车后座可以放一个枪架，但你却不能在公共场所给宝宝喂母乳，而这正是乳房本来的用途。”她接着说，这可能激发了《迎婴派对》这一集中的一个场景灵感。当时我想，哦对，我记得拍过一个她在哺乳的镜头，但我觉得它最后没有剪进正片里。
No, it did not. But it is in the deleted scene section on the DVDs. And basically Jan just is like, it's time to breastfeed. And she starts breastfeeding her baby in the office. And of course, Kevin is totally preoccupied by it. I would play it, but it's more of a visual joke. But you know, I'm so glad you found that quote, because Jenna, I remember that about Melora. I remember we were going to rehearse a scene in the parking lot. And she was walking up towards us and she had one of those baby slings on and her baby was in it.
不，确实没有。但它在DVD的删减片段里。基本上就是简觉得：是时候喂母乳了。然后她就开始在办公室里给宝宝喂母乳。当然，凯文对此完全魂不守舍。本想放出来看看的，但这更多是一个视觉笑话。不过你知道的，我很高兴你找到了那段引言，因为珍娜，我对梅洛拉确实有这个印象。我记得我们当时准备在停车场排练一场戏。她朝我们走过来，身上背着那种婴儿背带，宝宝就在里面。
And as she approached us, she was just talking, you know, like we're gonna map out the scene. And her baby was nursing the whole time. And she just was like, zero Fs. I am living my life, my baby's nursing, and I'm also working. I am multitasking, cause I am a freaking amazing woman.
当她走近我们时，她就在那儿说话，你知道的，就像我们要规划这场戏一样。而且她的宝宝全程都在吃奶。她给人的感觉就是：完全不在乎别人的眼光（zero Fs）。我过我的人生，我宝宝在吃奶，我也在工作。我在进行多任务处理，因为我是一个了不起的超级女性。
Well, she was so inspiring to me because I just have those same memories of her. I was so far from having kids when I first met her and I saw that and it was just really great modeling for me. I remember sitting and having lunch with her and she was nursing her baby. I remember reading through scenes with her and she was nursing her baby. She was very committed to it and
嗯，她对我的启发太大了，因为我对她有着完全相同的记忆。我刚认识她时，离生孩子还早得很，我看到了那一幕，这对我来说真的是非常棒的榜样。我记得坐下来和她一起吃午饭，她在给宝宝喂母乳。我记得和她一起过剧本，她在给宝宝喂母乳。她对这件事非常投入，而且
unapologetic. Yeah. I loved it. It was like a way that she was such a trailblazer for me. Yeah and Jan has the same feelings. She sure did. She sure did. Okay everyone next week August 14th we are back breaking down the farm. It is a great episode. I mean, dare I say it is one of our best breakdowns. We produced this one with our new partner Odyssey and I think you're going to feel a really fun new energy. And just remember you don't have to do anything different to your feed. If you are subscribed to Office Ladies, you'll just keep getting episodes just like before
毫不掩饰。是的。我很喜欢。对我而言，她就像是一位开路先锋。是的，简也有同样的感受。她当然有。她当然有。好了，各位，下周8月14日，我们将回归分解《农场》。这是一集很棒的剧集。我是说，我敢说这是我们最棒的分解之一。我们与新合作伙伴奥德赛（Odyssey）共同制作了这一集，我想你们会感受到一股非常有趣的新能量。请记住，你们的订阅源不需要做任何改变。如果你已经订阅了《办公室女士》（Office Ladies），你们会像以前一样继续收到剧集
and we will still be on all of the podcast platforms, and we can't wait for you to hear this episode. Here's our rerun of Baby Shower, and then we'll see you next week. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends.
而且我们仍将活跃于各大播客平台，我们迫不及待地想让你们听到这一集。以下是我们的《迎婴派对》重播，我们下周见。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是好朋友。
And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Are you ready for a baby shower? I sure am. It's Jan's baby shower today.
现在，我们将为你带来专属于你的终极《办公室》重刷播客。每周，我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是“办公室女士”。你准备好迎接迎婴派对了吗？我当然准备好了。今天是简的迎婴派对。
At a company she no longer works at, with a man she no longer dates and is not the father of her baby, it's going to be a huge success. Oh yeah. All the elements are there. Right? Yes. People she doesn't really like are throwing her a baby shower. And they don't like her. It's going to be great. It's season five, episode four. This episode was written by Erin Shure and directed by Greg Daniels. I have a summary. Let's do it. Michael and the party planning committee, still headed
在一个她早已不在那里工作、和一个她不再约会且不是她孩子父亲的男人一起举办，这绝对会是一场巨大的成功。哦，耶。所有要素都齐了。对吧？是的。那些并不是真正喜欢她的人正在为她举办迎婴派对。而她也不喜欢他们。这绝对会很棒。这是第五季第四集。这一集由埃林·舒尔（Erin Shure）编剧，格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）导演。我有一个剧情概要。我们开始吧。迈克尔和派对策划委员会——依然由
by Phyllis, throw a baby shower for Jan, but they are unaware that she has already given birth to her daughter Astrid. Jan's presence in the office causes Michael to be rude to Holly, and Dwight spends the day putting Jan's luxury stroller to the test. Meanwhile, Jim and Pam feel the effects of their long-distance relationship. Oh, that was hard to watch. They were out of sync. They were. You don't like to see that.
菲利斯领导——为简举办了一个迎婴派对，但他们并不知道简已经生下了女儿阿斯特丽德（Astrid）。简在办公室的出现导致迈克尔对霍莉态度粗鲁，而德怀特则花了一整天时间测试简的豪华婴儿车。与此同时，吉姆和帕姆感受到了异地恋带来的影响。哦，那一幕真难看。他们不在一个频道上。确实不在。你可不想看到这一幕。
No, I don't. Fast fact number one, new writer alert. Erin Sher joined the writing staff this year in season five. Erin had been a writer on Everybody Loves Raymond, which is one of my favorite sitcoms of all time. It is such a great ensemble sitcom. Do you know that one where Marie goes to art class and she makes the sculpture?
不，我不想。趣味冷知识一：新编剧警报。埃林·舍尔今年加入了第五季的编剧团队。埃林曾是《人人都爱雷蒙德》的编剧，那是我有史以来最喜欢的的情景喜剧之一。它真是一部非常棒的群戏情景喜剧。你知道那一集吗？玛丽去上艺术课，她做了一个雕塑？
And then, guys, look it up. She makes a sculpture and she's so proud and she unveils it and it looks like a vagina. But she doesn't know, but everybody else is like, Marie, what inspired you to make this piece? Oh my gosh. It's so good. Her character was so good. So anyway, I was very excited to have Aaron join the writing staff because then I could ask him tons of questions about Everybody Loves Raymond. And you did. I did. You chatted him up
然后，伙计们，你们去查查。她做了一个雕塑，而且她非常骄傲，当她揭开它的时候，它看起来就像一个阴道。但她自己不知道，而其他人都在问：玛丽，是什么启发你创作了这件作品？哦天哪。太棒了。她的角色太棒了。所以总之，我很兴奋能让埃林加入编剧团队，因为这样我就可以问他关于《人人都爱雷蒙德》的无数问题了。你确实问了。我确实问了。你跟他聊了
a lot about it. Well, we have some news. Angela, do you want to share? I do. So I reached out to Aaron. We had been trying to get ahold of him. You slid into his DMs. I did. He was like, I don't even know. Do I have DMs? I'm like, yes. But I found an old email and we got in touch and it was so fun to talk to him. He's a huge fan of the podcast. Jenna, he told me that he listens to the podcast in the evenings and then sometimes when he drifts off to sleep, he dreams like that he's in the podcast with us. Oh my goodness. Is that a good dream or a nightmare? I don't know. I hope it's a good thing. I hope so.
很多关于那部剧的事。好吧，我们有个好消息。安吉拉，你想分享一下吗？我想。所以，我联系了埃林。我们之前一直试图联系他。你私信（DM）了他。我确实联系了。他当时说：我甚至不知道，我有什么私信功能吗？我说：有的。但我翻到了一封旧邮件，我们取得了联系，和他聊天太有趣了。他是这个播客的超级粉丝。珍娜，他告诉我，他经常在晚上听这个播客，有时当他快要入睡时，他甚至会梦见自己和我们一起在播客里。噢天哪。那是好梦还是噩梦？我不知道。我希望是件好事。希望如此。
Aaron had lots of great stuff to share. We're going to hit him up quite a bit. We have Aaron now, we have James, and also Randy Cordray. Yes. When Angela told me that she got a hold of Aaron, I know you were going to ask him about the office, but I had an everybody loves Raymond question. Still, this poor man, I cornered him on set and now you're calling him on the phone and my question is still about everybody loves Raymond. But here's the thing. I remember that there was this episode
埃林有很多精彩的内容可以分享。我们要经常找他聊聊。我们现在有了埃林，有了詹姆斯，还有兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray）。是的。当安吉拉告诉我她联系上了埃林时，我知道你肯定是要问他关于《办公室》的事，但我有一个关于《人人都爱雷蒙德》的问题。结果呢，这个可怜的人，我在片场把他堵在角落里，现在你又给他打电话，而我的问题居然还是关于《人人都爱雷蒙德》的。但事情是这样的。我记得有这样一集
that was based on a story from his real life, but I couldn't remember all the details. It's the episode, it's called 10th anniversary. And Ray and Deborah are celebrating their 10th anniversary and they want to watch their wedding tape and they get it out and they put it in the VCR, they press play and Ray has recorded a football game over their wedding tape. And I remember that there is some story where I think Aaron recorded over his wedding tape with his wife. That is true. I knew it. That is true. So this is what happened. Okay,
它是根据他真实生活中的一个故事改编的，但我记不清所有细节了。那一集叫做《十周年》。雷和黛博拉在庆祝他们的结婚十周年，他们想看自己的婚礼录像带，于是拿出来放进VCR，按下播放键，结果雷竟然在他们的婚礼录像带上录了一场橄榄球比赛。我记得有个故事是说，好像埃林用橄榄球赛覆盖了他和妻子的婚礼录像带。这是真的。我就知道。这是真的。所以事情是这样的。好吧，
so Aaron was a fan of Everybody Loves Raymond. It was a show he wanted to meet on. So he thought, oh, I'll record a few episodes, watch them, really study the show. So when I go in and meet, you know, I have all this information. So he popped in VHS, guys, this dates us all a little bit. And he hit record and it was his wedding video. Yeah. And back then, you guys, it's not like you have multiple copies. Like you get your wedding videotape and that's it.
埃林是《人人都爱雷蒙德》的粉丝。那是他很想去面试的一部剧。所以他想，哦，我要录几集下来看看，好好研究一下这部剧。这样当我去面试时，你知道的，我就掌握了所有信息。于是他放进了一盘录像带，伙计们，这有点暴露我们的年龄了。他按下录像键，结果那竟然是他的婚礼录像。是的。而在当时，伙计们，可不像现在这样能有多份拷贝。你的婚礼录像带就只有那一盘，没了。
Yeah. Yeah, his wife was really upset. Oh no. And he went in to meet on Everybody Loves Raymond and he told that story. He was like, I taped over my wedding video to watch Everybody Loves Raymond. So my wife is really mad.
是的。是的，他妻子非常生气。哦，不。然后他去参加《人人都爱雷蒙德》的面试时，讲了这个故事。他说：我把自己的婚礼录像给录掉了，为了看《人人都爱雷蒙德》。所以我的妻子真的很生气。
You got to give me this job. And he got the job. And then that story made it into an episode. Yes. Oh, I love it. A lot of Aaron's life ends up in scripts, you guys. There's a few episodes coming up that his actual life inspired things that Michael does. And I can't wait to share those with you.
你必须把这份工作给我。然后他就得到了这份工作。后来这个故事就被写进了一集剧本里。是的。哦，我太喜欢了。埃林生活中的很多事最终都进了剧本，伙计们。接下来有几集，迈克尔做的一些事就是由他的真实生活启发而来的。我迫不及待地想跟你们分享。
I'm so glad we're in touch with him. I know. Fast fact number two, Angela, we shot this episode in August of 2008. And since we brought it up before, I thought it was worth mentioning that this same month, Steve Carell won his second surfboard at the 2008 Teen Choice Awards for TV Comedy Actor.
我很高兴我们能与他保持联系。我知道。趣味冷知识二：安吉拉，我们在2008年8月拍摄了这一集。既然之前已经提过了，我觉得值得一提的是，就在同个月，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在2008年青少年选择奖上赢得了他的第二块冲浪板，荣获电视喜剧男演员奖。
Steve, where did you put your surfboards? Back to back surfboards. Wow. When we have them on the podcast, is it going to be weird if we ask him where his surfboards are? It depends where you put them. It's going to be such a weird question. Well, also this same year, the movie Juno won best comedy movie and Rain Wilson was in that. Also this same year, we won a SAG award. Yes. So this was like the awards and the surfboards were coming in now. Yeah. Right. It was really cool. And I remember at the 2008 SAG awards, we were sitting at the table and everybody was
史蒂夫，你把你的冲浪板放在哪儿了？背靠背的两块冲浪板。哇。当他在我们的播客做客时，如果我们问他冲浪板放哪儿了，会不会很奇怪？这取决于你把它们放在哪儿。这将会是一个非常奇怪的问题。嗯，同样是在这一年，电影《朱诺》赢得了最佳喜剧电影，雷恩·威尔逊也参演了那部电影。还是在这一年，我们赢得了一个演员工会奖（SAG）。是的。所以当时的奖项和冲浪板真的是接踵而至。是的。对吧。真的很酷。我记得在2008年的演员工会奖颁奖典礼上，我们坐在桌子旁，每个人都在
like, who's going to give the speech if we win? And we all assumed it would be Steve, like Steve will give the speech. And Steve said, guys, this is an ensemble. I don't want to always speak for the cast. That doesn't feel right to me. This is an ensemble award. I think someone else should speak. And I mean, first of all, amazing, right?
讨论：如果我们赢了，谁来发表获奖感言？我们都以为会是史蒂夫，觉得史蒂夫会上台发言。史蒂夫却说：伙计们，这是一个集体奖。我不想总是代表演员们发言。这让我觉得不太合适。这是一个集体奖项。我觉得应该由其他人来发言。我是说，首先，太棒了，对吧？
Like, Steve's awesome. And so then Rain said, I think Jenna should do it. And I feel like none of us really thought we were going to win, because we'd won the year before. And I said, oh, OK, yeah, sure, I'll do it. And then we won. And I had to give a speech at an award show.
就像史蒂夫那样令人赞叹。然后雷恩说，我觉得应该让珍娜去。我觉得我们当时谁都没真的觉得自己会赢，因为我们前一年刚赢过。我说：哦，好吧，行，我来。然后我们真的赢了。我不得不在一个颁奖典礼上发表感言。
And you did such a great job. You were so articulate and well-spoken. I was in awe because we didn't think we were going to win. It was a total surprise. And then we won and I'm like walking to the stage and I'm like, oh my God. Well I know you guys are tired of me talking about being pregnant, but I was pregnant at that award show. And it's a very odd thing to be super huge and pregnant at an award show. But you did such a great job. Thank you.
你当时表现得太棒了。你表达得非常清晰流畅。我当时惊呆了，因为我们根本没想过会赢。这完全是个惊喜。然后我们赢了，我一边走上舞台一边想：哦，天哪。好吧，我知道你们可能听烦了我谈论怀孕的事，但我在那个颁奖典礼上确实怀孕了。在一个颁奖典礼上挺着个巨大的孕肚，这感觉真的很奇妙。但你真的表现得太棒了。谢谢。
I ended up kind of going down a rabbit hole of all the like cool things that happened for our show in 2008. It was a good year. It was a good year. James Carey sent me the call sheet for this episode. Jamesapedia. Jamesapedia. And on the call sheet, it said, there is a screening of Rainn Wilson's new movie,
我最后不知怎么陷入了一个“兔子洞”，去盘点2008年我们剧组发生的所有那些酷炫的事情。那是美好的一年。确实是美好的一年。詹姆斯·凯瑞（James Carey）给我发了这一集的通告单。詹姆斯百科（Jamespedia）。詹姆斯百科。通告单上写着：
The Rocker at Universal City Walk for the cast and crew. All are welcome. So that was also happening. So what happening? All right. Fast fact number three. This episode is a baby shower. So I'm going to tell you some stuff about baby showers. You did a deep dive on baby showers? I did. What is there to know? It's a baby coming. Get some presents. Get everyone ready. What else is there to know? Well, baby showers are believed to date all the way back to the Egyptian and Greek civilizations. Whoa! But baby showers, as we know them today, began during the baby boom era of World War II.
在环球影城步行街（Universal City Walk）为演员和剧组放映雷恩·威尔逊的新电影《摇滚之王》（The Rocker）。欢迎所有人参加。所以当时还有这事。还有这事呢。好吧。趣味冷知识三：这一集是一个迎婴派对。所以我来跟你们讲讲关于迎婴派对的一些事。你对迎婴派对做了一番深入研究？我确实做了。迎婴派对有什么好知道的？不就是一个宝宝要出生了吗。收点礼物。让大家做好准备。还有什么要知道的？嗯，人们认为迎婴派对最早可以追溯到古埃及和古希腊文明。哇！但我们今天所熟知的迎婴派对，始于二战时期的婴儿潮时代。
So traditionally, the baby shower was thrown by a close family member or a friend and the mother-to-be opened gifts in a decorated chair. Well, Jan has a very decorated chair. I noticed. Yeah, thank you party planning committee. Thank you, Phyllis. Well, I think Angela did it
所以传统上，迎婴派对是由近亲或朋友举办的，准妈妈会坐在一把装饰精美的椅子上拆礼物。嗯，简确实有一把装饰非常精美的椅子。我注意到了。是的，谢谢派对策划委员会。谢谢菲利斯。嗯，我觉得其实是安吉拉做的
because Phyllis is making her do everything. So thank you, Angela. Okay. I don't know. Well, listen, Angela did it because Phyllis is making her do everything. So thank you, Angela. Okay. I don't know. Well, listen, nowadays we have all kinds of ways that we can celebrate a new baby. And here are some new updated baby showers. A diaper shower. That's where all you bring are diapers in different sizes.
因为菲利斯把所有活都推给她干了。所以谢谢安吉拉。好吧。我不知道。好吧，听着，其实是安吉拉干的，因为菲利斯把所有活都堆给她了。所以谢谢安吉拉。好吧。我不知道。好吧，听着，现在我们有很多种方式来庆祝新宝宝的降临，以下是一些新型的现代迎婴派对。纸尿裤派对（A diaper shower）。就是所有人带给你的只有各种尺寸的纸尿裤。
It's like if you go to your baby shower, it's like you went to Costco and bought out all the diapers. You just go home with every diaper because diapers are expensive. What's the next one? Grandparents shower. This is a shower that you throw for the grandparents and you give them stuff to keep at their house for when the baby comes over. keep at their house for when the baby comes over. Mm, boo. I'm saying, I love you grandparents, but come on. Grandparents, they love to go get that stuff. Yeah, I don't know.
这就好像你去参加迎婴派对，结果感觉像是去了好市多（Costco）把所有的纸尿裤都买光了一样。你回到家时带的全是纸尿裤，因为纸尿裤很贵。下一个是什么？祖父母派对（Grandparents shower）。这是一个为你父母举办的派对，大家送他们一些东西放在家里，等宝宝过去玩的时候用。放在家里等宝宝过去用。嗯，不。我想说，我爱你们，祖父母们，但拜托。祖父母们，他们可太喜欢去买那些东西了。是的，我不知道。
Here's another one. I've heard of these, a sprinkle. What? You don't have a baby shower, you have a sprinkle. Sounds like you're going pee. It does. This is a shower that you throw for your second or third or fourth babies to collect maybe some of the things
还有另一个。我听说过这种，叫做“宝贝细雨派对”（a sprinkle）。什么？你不是办迎婴派对，你办的是一个“细雨派对”。听起来像是在上厕所（pee）。确实。这是为你生第二个、第三个或第四个孩子时举办的派对，主要为了收集一些
if you are having a baby of a different gender. Right, right. Or if you need to refresh. Oh my god, I just got it. A shower and a sprinkle. Yeah. It's not a full shower. It's just a sprinkle.
如果你这次怀的是不同性别的宝宝而可能需要的东西。对，对。或者如果你需要补充一些新装备。哦天哪，我刚刚明白了。“淋浴/派对”（A shower）和“细雨”（a sprinkle）。对。这不是一场倾盆大雨般的派对（Full shower）。这只是一场毛毛雨（A sprinkle）。
Every time you say it, I just think of tinkling. I do too. All right, the final one is a sip and see. Does this involve wine? It does. It is a celebration planned by the new parents after the baby has arrived. Oh, you sip and you get to see the baby.
每次你这么说，我就只想到了滴尿。我也是。好吧，最后一个是“啜饮与探视派对”（a sip and see）。这跟酒有关吗？有关的。这是由新手父母在宝宝出生后策划的一场庆祝活动。哦，你一边啜饮美酒，一边去看看宝宝。
Yes, so I have to say what we are going to see in this episode is technically a Sip and See. You know what? I have been to a Sip and See, but I didn't even know it. I love the name Sip and See. Sip and See. Can I have a Sip and See for my new puppy? Can I do that?
对，所以我得说，我们在这一集里看到的情节，技术上讲就是一个“啜饮与探视派对”。你知道吗？我以前去过“啜饮与探视派对”，但我当时甚至都不知道这叫这名。我超喜欢“啜饮与探视”这个名字。啜饮与探视。我能为我的新小狗办一场“啜饮与探视”吗？我能这么做吗？
Yes. Okay, good. That's all I got, Ann. Anything you want to add? Do you have a Kinsey tidbit today? Well, here's a little Kinsey tidbit. One of the things Erin said, which we have talked about before, is how long these scripts came in. You know, they were pretty big episodes,
可以。好吧，太好了。埃林，我收集的就这些了。你有什么要补充的吗？你今天有什么金斯利小花絮吗？好吧，这里有一个金斯利小花絮。埃林说过的一件事——我们之前也讨论过——就是这些剧本写得太长了。你知道的，它们本来都是挺宏大的剧集，
and then we would have to just chisel away, and there was so much that didn't make it to the screen. For example, this episode came in at 49 pages, right? Wait, what? The script for this was 49 pages? Yeah, 49 pages. That's craziness. And you know how we've talked about how they would sort of rebuild the episodes in editing? Well, Aaron had this quote that I absolutely loved. He said that Greg liked to rebuild the ship at sea.
然后我们不得不精简删改，有很多内容最终都没有出现在屏幕上。比如，这一集最初的剧本长达49页，对吧？等等，什么？这一集的剧本有49页？对，49页。这太疯狂了。而且你知道我们之前讨论过他们是如何在剪辑阶段重新构建剧集的吗？嗯，埃林有一句话我超级喜欢。他说格雷格喜欢“在航行中重建船只”。
Oh, yeah. Isn't that such a great phrase? I love that. I just love that. They would get in the editor's room, man, yeah. Isn't that such a great phrase? I love that. I just love that. They would get in the editor's room, man, and they would just carve it up. And I told him, I said, it's always interesting for me now that we have all these scripts. Thank you, James, to see what makes it on the screen and what doesn't and how they move everything around.
哦，对。这不是一个绝妙的比喻吗？我太喜欢了。我就是喜欢这样。他们会走进剪辑室，天哪，是的。这不是一个绝妙的比喻吗？我太喜欢了。我就是喜欢这样。他们会走进剪辑室，天哪，然后他们就会大刀阔斧地把它雕琢出来。我告诉他，我说，现在我们有了所有这些剧本，对我来说总是很有趣。谢谢詹姆斯，能看到最后什么播出了，什么没播出，以及他们是如何调整所有这些内容的。
And I'm always so happy with the final product, you know? But it's a cool thing to see. But I thought that Greg likes to rebuild the ship at sea was like a great phrase. Well, I think those were really good fast facts and we've got some more Aaron tidbits. We should take a break and get into this episode. I like it.
而且我对最终成片总是感到很满意，你知道的？但能看到这个过程真的很酷。我觉得“格雷格喜欢在航行中重建船只”真是一个绝妙的比喻。嗯，我觉得这些冷知识真的很棒，而且我们还有更多关于埃林的独家花絮。我们应该休息一下，然后正式进入这一集。我喜欢。
All right, we are back. All right, we are back and you guys at 12 seconds, everything you need to know about this episode is laid out by Jim. Jim has a dry erase board and he's going to tell you everything you need to know about this episode. Sam, can you play that clip? Jan is about to have a baby with a sperm donor. And Michael is preparing for the birth of a watermelon with Dwight. Now, this baby will be related to Michael through
好的，我们回来了。好的，我们回来了，伙计们，在第12秒时，关于这一集你需要知道的一切都被吉姆列出来了。吉姆拿着一块干擦白板，他要告诉你关于这一集你需要知道的一切。萨姆，你能播放那个片段吗？简即将通过精子捐赠者生一个孩子。而迈克尔则正和德怀特一起为孕育一个西瓜做准备。现在，这个孩子将通过
delusion. There you go. That pretty much sums it up. That could have been the summary. I know, right? When I saw that, I was like, well, that's everything you need to know. Did you catch the? When I saw that, I was like, well, that's everything you need to know. Did you catch the Dwight?
妄想与迈克尔产生亲缘关系。给你。差不多就概括完了。这完全可以当剧情概要了。我知道，对吧？我当时看到那段时就想，好吧，这就是你需要知道的一切。你捕捉到了吗？我当时看到那段时就想，好吧，这就是你需要知道的一切。你捕捉到了吗，德怀特？
I know. I was about to say, Anne, you got a real good Dwight in there. Well, it's true. Dwight is walking around. He's got a watermelon in his smock that he's wearing. Yeah. An apron? They've fastened like a smock to hold the baby.
我知道。我正要说呢，埃林，你刚才模仿德怀特模仿得太像了。嗯，确实如此。德怀特到处走动。他的罩衫里塞了一个西瓜。是的。围裙？他们把类似于罩衫的东西固定在身上来模拟抱婴儿。
Yeah, the watermelon baby. Do you have some Phil Shea trivia about this? I do. Yay! I talked to Phil Shea for about an hour yesterday. Prop master extraordinaire. I know. And we are going to have him on for an extended interview because he has got just some great info and stories. I can't wait. We need to have Aaron Schur on too. We really do. Let's load it up. All right. We had a fan question from Lisa W. How many watermelons were needed to do the practice birth scene with Michael and Dwight?
对，西瓜宝宝。你有什么关于菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）的幕后趣闻吗？我有！耶！我昨天跟菲尔·谢伊聊了大约一个小时。道具大师中的大师。我知道。我们打算邀请他进行一次深入的长篇访谈，因为他手里有太多精彩的信息和故事了。我等不及了。我们也得把埃林·舒尔请来。真的得请。我们安排上。好的。我们有一个来自丽莎·W的粉丝提问：拍迈克尔和德怀特的模拟分娩戏时，一共需要多少个西瓜？
Phil said in total, we used about 30 watermelons for this whole episode. Oh, because he straps it into the stroller later. So for these scenes and for later. And Phil said, you know, it's great living in Southern California because you can get watermelons all year. So it wasn't a problem. Okay. Yeah. Fan catch from Evelyn V said at one minute 41 seconds, I think I can see other
菲尔说总共大约用了30个西瓜来拍这一整集。哦，因为他后来把西瓜绑在婴儿车里了。所以是为了这些戏以及后来的戏。菲尔说，你知道的，住在南加州真的很棒，因为你一年四季都能买到西瓜。所以这不是问题。好的。是的。来自伊芙琳·V的粉丝抓包说：在1分41秒时，我觉得我能看到之前几条拍摄中西瓜砸在地上留下的其他
stains from when the watermelon crashed into the ground on previous takes. I looked at it. Evelyn, I think that's a stain from something else. I don't think it's a watermelon. I feel like as Pam, I have walked up to the front of Michael's desk and I've looked down at my feet enough in scenes. I recognize that stain. I don't know what that's from.
污渍。我看了那一幕。伊芙琳，我觉得那是其他东西留下的污渍。我觉得那不是西瓜。我觉得作为帕姆，我在场景里走到迈克尔桌子前面，低头看自己脚下的次数够多了。我认得那个污渍。我不知道那是从哪儿来的。
I don't think it was watermelons. I don't know what to make of that other than maybe we should have splurged for new carpet. I think Michael needs new carpet. We had this letter from Ben M in Chicago. I am an ER doctor and whenever I'm teaching medical students how to deliver a baby, I like to show them the cold open from this episode. Get out.
我不觉得那是西瓜弄的。除了我们当时也许该花大钱换个新地毯之外，我实在想不出别的解释了。我觉得迈克尔需要一块新地毯。我们收到了来自芝加哥的本·M的来信。我是一名急诊科医生，每当我教医学生如何接生时，我都喜欢给他们看这一集的开场白。少来。
Yes. This reinforces to them that newborns are very slippery. Oh, come on. It helps teach them that you must always support the baby's head and neck and also hold an arm or a leg immediately after delivery. It is a very funny cold open, but also extremely accurate. Wow.
是的。这向他们强调了新生儿是非常滑的。哦，拜托。这有助于教导他们，分娩后必须始终托住婴儿的头部和颈部，并且要在分娩后立即托住手臂或腿部。这是一个非常搞笑的开场白，但同时也极其准确。哇。
Yeah. Well, Erin told me that this whole cold open was Greg's idea. The watermelon, the whole thing. Wow. Yeah. Well, Aaron told me that this whole cold open was Greg's idea, the watermelon, the whole thing. Okay. He had this whole idea and Aaron just ran with it. It's funny you say that because when I spoke with Phil, he said, I think Greg had an affinity for Gallagher. That's why you see so many watermelon gags on our show. That is very funny. Yeah. The comedian Gallagher, he used to smash watermelons and if you were on the front row, you just get splattered. Yeah.
是的。嗯，埃林告诉我，整个开场白都是格雷格的主意。西瓜，还有整件事。哇。是的。嗯，埃林告诉我，整个开场白都是格雷格的主意，西瓜，还有整件事。好吧。他当时有这整套构思，而埃林只是顺着这个思路发挥了。说得真对，因为我跟菲尔谈过时，他说，我觉得格雷格对加拉格尔（Gallagher）有一种偏爱。这就是为什么我们的节目里能看到那么多砸西瓜的恶作剧。太搞笑了。是的。喜剧演员加拉格尔，他以前经常砸西瓜，如果你坐在第一排，就会被溅得满脸都是。是的。
I think that was it. Aaron told me, because after he spoke with you, he came to the DM. Oh, he found you. We DM'd. Oh, good. He said this cold open was the first thing they shot and it was his first time on set for the office and he kept laughing out loud and Greg had to say to him, Aaron, this is not Everybody Loves Raymond. It's not a live show. You can't laugh out loud. And he was like, oh no. Yes. He told me that it became
我想就是这样。埃林告诉我，因为在他跟你聊过之后，他来私信了我。哦，他找到你了。我们私信了。哦，太好了。他说这个开场白是他们拍的第一场戏，这也是他第一次来到《办公室》的片场，他一直在大笑，以至于格雷格不得不对他说：埃林，这不是《人人都爱雷蒙德》。这不是现场直播秀。你不能笑出声来。然后他的反应是：哦，不。是的。他告诉我，这成了
a thing he became very self-conscious about because he'd only ever worked in four camera where they encourage you to laugh and laugh and laugh. And then he had to start suppressing the laugh and suppressing the laugh. And he said, to start suppressing the laugh and suppressing the laugh. And he said, after a long day of work and suppressing the laugh, he would go home and just burp constantly. He told me that too. He had given himself like some type of indigestion
一件让他非常自我意识过剩的事，因为他以前只在四机拍摄的情景喜剧里工作过，在那儿人们总是鼓励你笑，大笑，狂笑。然后他不得不开始强忍住笑，强忍住笑。并且他说，开始强忍住笑，强忍住笑。然后他表示，经过一整天的工作并极力忍住笑之后，他回到家就会不停地打嗝。他连这也跟我说了！他因为一整天憋笑
from holding in laughter all day. Well, you guys, this was very hard to watch without laughing for all of us. And if you go to one minute, 11 seconds, Phyll very hard to watch without laughing for all of us. And if you go to 1 minute, 11 seconds, Phyllis had to put her head down because she was laughing so hard. The shot of the bullpen reacting. Yeah, was so funny to me. Well, there is a lot in this episode that we could not get through. Oh man, the conference room, we'll get there. I think we should get to the party planning committee now because they have been very
竟然给自己憋出了某种消化不良。好吧，伙计们，对我们所有人来说，要在这一集里忍住不笑真的太难了。如果你看1分11秒，菲尔对我们所有人来说要忍住不笑真的太难了。如果你看1分11秒，菲尔不得不把头埋下去，因为她笑得太厉害了。办公区众人反应的那个镜头。是的，我觉得太搞笑了。嗯，这一集里有很多内容是我们根本无法一口气拍完的。哦天哪，会议室那段，我们待会儿说到。我觉得我们现在应该进入派对策划委员会的戏份了，因为她们一直在忙着
busy decorating the conference room for the shower. They have two bowls of M&Ms. So I talked to Aaron about this and I said, who came up with Astrid and Chevy? And he said Astrid was definitely Greg. He thought it'd be funny to see that name on an M&M. And then Chevy, he couldn't remember who came up with that. He said he thinks the room kind of pitched names. It's funny when I saw the bowls of M&Ms with the names, that was like a really popular thing. It might still be popular where you can get these personalized M&Ms. Oh, I went to the website.
为迎婴派对布置会议室。她们准备了两碗M&M巧克力豆。所以我跟埃林聊到了这个，我问：是谁想出了“阿斯特丽德”（Astrid）和“雪佛莱”（Chevy）这两个名字？他说“阿斯特丽德”绝对是格雷格的主意。他觉得能在M&M豆上看到那个名字会很有趣。至于“雪佛莱”，他记不清是谁想出来的了。他说他觉得大家当时在房间里七嘴八舌地抛出了各种名字。说来有趣，当我看到那些印着名字的M&M巧克力豆碗时，那在当时绝对是个超级流行的点子。现在可能依然很流行，就是那种你可以定制专属的M&M豆。哦，我去过那个网站。
It's still a whole thing. High school graduation, anniversaries, and I did this for my parents. My parents' anniversary. I got M&Ms with their names on it. Well, when we did the Jim and Pam wedding episode, Greg threw the cast a viewing party that was kind of like a little mini reception, and he had bowls of M&Ms that said Jim and Pam.
这至今还是个热门项目。高中毕业、周年纪念，我还给我父母做过这个。我父母的结婚纪念日。我定制了印有他们名字的M&M豆。嗯，我们在拍吉姆和帕姆的婚礼那一集时，格雷格为全体演员办了一场观影派对，有点像是一个小型招待会，他当时就准备了印有“吉姆和帕姆”字样的M&M巧克力豆。
He clearly was a big fan. He loved that you could personalize an M&M. I know. Well, they've gotten the name wrong though. The party planning committee has Ass Turd. Phyllis is like, that can't be right. Angela's like, Michael wrote down Ass Turd. Michael said, yeah, it's like the name of a Viking princess.
他显然是个超级粉丝。他太喜欢可以在M&M豆上定制字样了。我知道。不过，她们把名字弄错了。派对策划委员会写的是“阿斯·特德”（Ass Turd）。菲利斯说：这名字绝对不对。安吉拉则说：迈克尔写的就是阿斯·特德。迈克尔说：对啊，这听起来就像是个维京公主的名字。
So of course I had to research Astrid. I didn't research Asturd. And he is right. Michael is right. According to the internet, Astrid has Norse, Danish, and Swedish roots. It can mean godly strength or divine beauty. And the name Astrid has been used by Norway's royal family for hundreds of years. You know, Michael is annoyed by their effort.
所以当然啦，我不得不去研究一下“阿斯特丽德”。我没去研究“阿斯·特德”。他是对的。迈克尔是对的。根据互联网的说法，“阿斯特丽德”有着北欧、丹麦和瑞典血统。它可以意为“神圣的力量”或“神圣的美丽”。而且“阿斯特丽德”这个名字已经被挪威皇室使用了好几百年了。你知道的，迈克尔对她们的敷衍工作感到很恼火。
He says, Phyllis, we gave you a whole golden shower. I want my golden shower. He does. And then he has this talking head where he says he's going to love this baby even if it isn't his, like that dog that nursed the tiger cub. Right? Bizarre, but also beautiful.
他说：菲利斯，我们当初可是为你办了一场盛大的金色淋浴派对（golden shower）。我也要我的金色淋浴派对。他确实这么说了。然后他有一段访谈镜头，说他会爱这个孩子，哪怕这孩子不是他的，就像那只给小老虎喂奶的狗一样。对吧？诡异，但也美丽。
It happens. Jenna, I looked it up and there are so many stories of dogs nursing tigers, but the one that caught my eye was on the Today Show in August of 2008. That's when we shot this episode. I know. And there was a safari park in Kansas with a white tiger named Sassy who had cubs, but she was too sassy to nurse them.
这种事确实会发生。珍娜，我查了资料，发现有很多狗给老虎喂奶的故事，但其中最吸引我眼球的是2008年8月《今日秀》（Today Show）上的一个报道。那正好是我们拍这一集的时候。我知道。堪萨斯州有一个野生动物园，里面有一只叫萨西（Sassy）的白母虎，她生了幼崽，但她脾气太暴躁了，根本不肯给它们喂奶。
OK. So a golden retriever stepped in, Isabella. Well, I would expect that from a golden retriever. I really would. What a good dog. Anyway, it just cracked me up that on the Today Show, there was a whole thing about Sassy and Isabella, and I think it ended up in our episode.
好吧。于是，一只金毛寻回犬挺身而出，它的名字叫伊abella（伊莎贝拉）。嗯，我绝对会期待金毛寻回犬这么做。我真的会。多好的狗狗啊。不管怎样，这让我觉得特别好笑：在《今日秀》上居然有一整段关于萨西和伊莎贝拉的报道，我觉得这个点子最终被用进我们的剧集里了。
Clearly it did. Michael is gonna bark orders at Phyllis. She's doing a talking head. I was supposed to be glaring at her in the background. And if you go to four minutes, 11 seconds, you can see me talking to Andy, and I'm so delighted that Phyllis is messing up. And then Michael walks in and kind of yells at her and says, make the party, make the party.
显然是的。迈克尔开始对菲利斯大发雷霆、颐指气使。她当时正在做访谈。我本来应该在背景里怒视着她的。如果你看4分11秒，你可以看到我在跟安迪说话，我为菲利斯把事情搞砸了而感到幸灾乐祸。然后迈克尔走进来，对她大吼大叫，说：搞定派对，搞定派对。
And then he leaves and Phyllis starts pumping the balloon. Well, Steve improvised walking back in and saying, pump it, pump it. He did. He did. That was all improv. We just started cracking up. I thought I could see you starting to break in the background of that. And Phyllis is starting to break too. So now Jim is at his desk and Pam is trying to tell him this story. I loved this. It was so funny. When she's like, Sarah Kaya comes in and he goes, oh wait, Sarah Kaya comes in? And she's like, no, Sarah Kaya comes in. And then at the very end of the scene when Dwight's like, who's Sarah Kaya comes in? That was improvised.
然后他走了出去，菲利斯开始用力打气球。嗯，史蒂夫即兴发挥，走回来喊道：打气，打气！他确实这么做了。他真的这么做了。那全都是即兴发挥。我们当时直接笑喷了。我当时觉得我能看到你在那个镜头的背景里开始笑场了。菲利斯也开始笑场了。所以现在吉姆坐在桌前，而帕姆正试图跟他说一个故事。我太喜欢这段了。简直太搞笑了。当她说：萨拉·卡亚（Sarah Kaya）进来了，然后吉姆说：哦等等，萨拉·卡亚进来了？然后她说：不，是萨拉·卡亚进来了。接着在那个场景的最后，当德怀特说：谁是萨拉·卡亚进来了？那是即兴发挥。
Rain improvised that, that's not in the script. Oh my gosh. I watched this and I feel like I have had these conversations. Yes. A hundred percent. And I love the line when she's like, why can't you just be in art school with me?
雷恩是即兴发挥的，剧本里根本没有。哦天哪。我看着这一幕，感觉自己也经历过这种对话。是的。百分之百。我太喜欢她说的这句台词了：“为什么你就不能跟我一起在艺术学校呢？”
Cause she's trying so hard to tell him the story. And you know, this is the beginning of this storyline with Jim and Pam, where we're going to show that this distance has gone on for a while, and maybe they're not connecting as easily as they used to. You know, long distance relationships are hard. And particularly when the people involved in your new life, the other person doesn't know. And it's kind of hard to keep track. Oh, yes. I mean, we experience this all the time when we go on locations.
因为她太努力地想把这个故事讲给他听了。你知道的，这是帕姆和吉姆这条故事线的开端，我们将展现这种距离感已经持续了一段时间，也许他们不像以前那样能轻易地心领神会了。你知道的，异地恋很难。尤其是当涉及你新生活中的那些人时，另一个人却根本不认识。而且很难跟上对方的生活圈。哦，是的。我是说，我们每次去外地拍外景时都会经历这种事。
Or I remember Lee went on location to shoot a movie and he was directing a film. And he's trying to tell me this hilarious story about some prop mishap that happened and everyone was laughing about these prop glasses. And I'm just like, I don't know who any of these people are. And what's really hard about it is that I like to be able to imagine the people or where they are. And we've talked about this when we get to a new place, we're like, send me a video of where you are so that when I'm talking to you, I know what your little apartment looks like, or I know what your room looks like.
或者我记得李去外地拍电影，他当时在担任导演。他试图跟我讲一个非常搞笑的故事，关于某个道具出了什么差错，大家都觉得那些道具眼镜超级好笑。而我当时的反应就是：我不认识这些人里的任何一个。这其中最难的地方在于，我希望能想象出那些人在哪里，或者他们在什么地方。我们谈过这个，当我们去到一个新地方时，我们会说：发个视频给我看看你在哪儿，这样当我和你说话时，我就知道你的小公寓长什么样，或者我知道你的房间长什么样。
Yeah, I have to have that. Otherwise, I'm a little unsettled because I can't picture where you are. Yes. So I feel like that's what Pam and Jim are up against right now. Yeah, he doesn't know her world. And it's some of that location situation kind of stuff. I love the next scene. I love it so much.
对，我必须得看到这个。否则我就会有点心神不定，因为我无法想象你所在的地方。对的。所以我觉得这就是帕姆和吉姆现在所面临的困境。是的，他不了解她的世界。这属于那种异地情境中的典型状况。我太喜欢接下来的这场戏了。我超级喜欢。
Angela is preparing this poster board full of baby photos because they're going to play a game where you have to guess which baby photo belongs to which employee and Andy comes in and he mistakes Phyllis's baby photo for Angela. Will you please tell me about shooting this scene, Angela? Well, one of the reasons I storm off is because I started to laugh. I could tell. That was me trying to get out of there before you saw me laughing on camera. So here's the thing, Greg directed this episode, right?
安吉拉正在准备一张贴满婴儿照片的海报板，因为她们要玩一个游戏：你必须猜出哪张婴儿照片属于哪位员工。这时安迪走了进来，他误把菲利斯小时候的婴儿照片当成了安吉拉的。安吉拉，你能跟我讲讲拍摄这场戏的经历吗？嗯，我之所以气冲冲地走开，是因为我当时笑场了。我看得出来。那是我试图在你看到我在镜头前笑出来之前赶紧溜走。事情是这样的，格雷格导演了这一集，对吧？
And he said, you guys, can you bring in your actual baby photos? And he said, if you don't have a baby photo, it could be like when you're a toddler, just can I get photos of you guys when you were little? And we did, right? We got a lot of fan mail about that. Were these actual photos of the cast? They were. Yeah.
他说：伙计们，你们能带自己真正的婴儿照片来吗？他说，如果你没有婴儿照片，也可以放一张你学步时的照片，总之能不能带点你们小时候的照片来？我们确实照做了，对吧？我们收到了很多关于这事的粉丝来信。这些真的是演员们自己的照片吗？是的。是的。
There's three people who aren't on the poster. Me, John and Steve. Everyone else is an actual baby photo from their childhood. Including Amy Ryan, she's up there. Yes. And so was Mindy. I mean, we're all on the board. Yeah.
有三个人的照片不在海报板上：我、约翰和史蒂夫。其他所有人的都是他们童年时期的真实婴儿照片。包括艾米·赖安（Amy Ryan），她也在上面。是的。明迪也在。我是说，我们所有人都在那个板上。对。
We're all on the board. Jenna, what did I bring in today? Do you want to share with them? You brought in your baby photo, the one that was on the board with your little hand up on your little chubby cheek. I know. I know. You guys, it's really me.
我们都在板上。珍娜，我今天带来了什么？你想跟他们分享一下吗？你带了你的婴儿照片，就是板上那张把一只小胖手托在胖乎乎的小脸蛋上的照片。我知道。我知道。伙计们，那真的是我。
I get asked this all the time. And my mom, I called my mom and I said, Mom, we're doing the baby shower episode and it's my baby photo and I want to know everything about it. She said, Oh, I have several more of that same day where we put you in different poses. Oh, so there's more. But here's what my mom said. She took me to JCPenney's at the Acadiana shopping mall in Lafayette, Louisiana. I was around six months old. And apparently I was born with just a ton of hair and it was sort of an auburn brown. She said I had so much hair, just right out of the gate.
我经常被问到这个问题。我给我妈打了电话，我说：妈，我们正在拍迎婴派对那一集，上面有我的婴儿照片，我想知道关于它的一切。她说：哦，同一天拍的照片我还有好几张，当时我们给你摆了不同的姿势。哦，所以还有更多照片。不过我妈是这么说的。她带我去了路易斯安那州拉斐特市阿卡迪亚购物中心（Acadiana Mall）的杰西潘尼（JCPenney）照相馆。我当时大约六个月大。显然我一出生就拥有一头浓密的头发，而且呈红褐色。她说我头发超级多，一出娘胎就这样。
I had tons of hair. And so she tried to style it for the photo. I was like, mom, you gave me like a Mohawk with bangs. So yeah, she said she had tried to put a little ribbon at the top. That would have made more sense. Right. But I don't know, it fell out or something. And then they propped me up on my hand like that.
我有一头浓密的头发。所以她当时想为照片给我做个造型。我当时想：妈，你简直给我弄了个莫霍克发型还带刘海。所以，她说她当时尝试在头顶扎了一个小蝴蝶结。那这样会合理得多。对吧。但我不知道，可能是掉了吧什么的。然后他们把我托在手上，就像这样。
It's so funny because I remember those photo studio photo shoots. That was a thing of my childhood as well. And they would have these carpeted blocks. Yes. And you would like be pro And they would have these carpeted blocks. Yes. And you would be propped up on a little carpeted block. I'm propped up because I can't sit yet, really. Yes. Anyway, there you go.
太搞笑了，因为我记得那种照相馆的拍摄。那也是我童年记忆的一部分。他们会有那种铺着地毯的方块道具。是的。然后你会把身体——他们会让你靠在一个铺着地毯的小方块上。我是被托着的，因为我还不会坐，真的不会。是的。不管怎样，就是这样。
That's my actual baby photo, you guys. Well, since mine wasn't on the board, I tell you what. I'll post mine on the Office Ladies pod so you can see me as a baby too. Yes. And I'll ask my mom if she can find any other photos from that particular photo shoot. Please. As Michael is preparing for Jan's arrival, he needs to tell Holly that he's
那就是我的真实婴儿照片，伙计们。好吧，既然我的不在板上，这样吧。我把我的照片发在“办公室女士”播客账号上，这样你们也能看到我小时候的样子了。好的。我还要问我妈能不能找到那次拍照的其他照片。拜托了。当迈克尔为简的到来做准备时，他需要告诉霍莉，他今天
going to be kind of cold to her today because he needs to protect Jan's feelings. Jan's bloated feelings. Yeah, because Jan is going to come in, she's going to Jan's bloated feelings. Yeah, because Jan is gonna come in, she's gonna be so unattractive. And Holly is very attractive. And yeah, he just wants to be sensitive. So he warns her. But then Jan arrives.
对她态度要冷淡一点，因为他需要保护简的感受。简那满腹怨气的臃肿感受。是的，因为简要来办公室了，她会显得很不迷人。而霍莉非常有魅力。所以他只想保持体贴。因此他先警告了霍莉。但接着简到了。
She's not pregnant. She has a baby. And she looks amazing. Yeah. But she's had the baby. We had a fan question from Brittany Y, Sarah M, and many more. Who is the baby that played Astrid? I will tell you, thanks to Jamesopedia.
她根本没怀孕。她已经把孩子生下来了。而且她看起来状态好极了。是的。但她已经把孩子生下来了。我们收到了来自布兰妮·Y、莎拉·M以及许多其他人的粉丝提问：扮演阿斯特丽德的宝宝是谁？我来告诉你们，多亏了詹姆斯百科。
First of all, you know, babies are played by many babies. Sometimes there are a set of twins, like in the case of Cece. Cece was this set of twins and it in the case of Cece, Cece was this set of twins and it was the same twin girls all through the show. They were absolute sweethearts and I loved them. But sometimes, especially with a baby this little, it's like three babies, five babies, lots of babies. Oh, Phillip was several different babies and then a different toddler. Yes. So this is because there are rules
首先，你们知道的，婴儿角色通常由好几个婴儿轮流扮演。有时是一对双胞胎，比如西西（Cece）的情况。西西是由一对双胞胎扮演的，整部剧里都是这一对双胞胎女孩。她们绝对是小甜心，我超级喜欢她们。但有时，尤其是对于这么小的婴儿，可能需要三个宝宝、五个宝宝，甚至很多宝宝。哦，菲利普（Phillip）是由好几个不同的婴儿扮演的，后来又换成了一个学步幼儿。是的。这是因为对于婴儿在片场工作有相关规定
about babies working on a set. They can only work for like 20 minutes. And I think that's a good thing. Yes. Also, if you have a baby and one of them's fussy, you can swap them out for a different baby. They're all dressed the same. You go backstage and there's like six babies
他们只能工作大约20分钟。我觉得这是一件好事。是的。另外，如果你有个宝宝哭闹不安，你就可以用另一个宝宝把她换下来。他们穿得一模一样。你走到后台，会发现大概有六个宝宝
in the same outfit. So Astrid was played first by a set of twins and another baby. Here's the crazy thing. The twins' names were Matthew and Joey Levinson. Crazy. Right? And they were playing Jan Levinson's baby. Yes. The other baby was Harvey Green. So her babies were the Levinson Green babies. Okay. So her babies were the Levinson Green babies. Okay.
穿着一模一样的衣服。所以阿斯特丽德最初是由一对双胞胎和另一个宝宝共同扮演的。疯狂的事情来了。那对双胞胎的名字叫马修·莱文森（Matthew Levinson）和乔伊·莱文森（Joey Levinson）。太疯狂了吧？对不对？而且他们扮演的是简·莱文森（Jan Levinson）的宝宝。是的。另一个宝宝叫哈维·格林（Harvey Green）。所以她的宝宝们其实是“莱文森-格林”宝宝组合。好吧。所以她的宝宝们其实是“莱文森-格林”宝宝组合。好吧。
All right. And then that was on one day. The other day we had a set of triplets playing Astrid. They were Chase, Chloe, and Juliet Purcell. So those are all the babies. We also had a fake baby. We did have a fake baby, yeah. And it's really funny because if you look at the call sheet, scene by scene, it'll say, real baby or fake baby.
好的。那是一天的情况。另一天，我们有一组三胞胎来扮演阿斯特丽德。他们是蔡斯、克洛伊和朱丽叶·珀塞尔（Chase, Chloe, and Juliet Purcell）。这些就是所有的宝宝们。我们还有一个假婴儿。我们确实有一个假婴儿，是的。而且非常搞笑的是，如果你看通告单，场次接场次地看，上面会写着：真婴儿或假婴儿。
Like what we're using in the scene. And they would stagger them, right? Cause the babies could only work for 20 minutes. So you'd have a scene with a real baby and then a scene with fake baby. Well, Michael walks out of the kitchen and he sees Jan with the baby. I can't imagine how he felt.
就像我们在场景里用的一样。他们会把这些交替错开，对吧？因为婴儿只能工作20分钟。所以你拍完一场真婴儿的戏，接着就会拍一场假婴儿的戏。嗯，迈克尔从厨房走出来，看到了抱着婴儿的简。我简直无法想象他当时的感受。
He'd been to all of his birthing classes with her and then he was sort of left out of this big moment and he confronts Jan about it. This is one of my favorite couplets of dialogue from the whole episode. Okay. It's so rich. Michael says, why didn't you call me? I could have helped. Jan said, well the birth instructor thought it wasn't a good idea for you to be there, so Michael says, oh man, him, that guy, he had no sense of humor and I proved him wrong in so many ways. And it just made me think about these classes. I wish we could have seen Michael trying to do comedy bits with like a birthing instructor. I would have loved to see that scene.
他跟她一起上了所有的产前分娩课，结果他却被晾在一边，错过了这个重大的时刻，于是他当面质问简。这是整集中我最喜欢的几句高能对话之一。好吧。太丰富了。迈克尔说：你为什么不打电话给我？我本可以帮忙的。简说：嗯，分娩指导老师觉得你在场并不是个好主意，所以迈克尔说：哦天哪，那家伙，他一点幽默感都没有，我在那么多方面向他证明他是错的。这让我不禁想起这些课程。我真希望我们能看到迈克尔试图跟产前分娩指导老师一起搞喜剧段子的样子。我好想看那场戏。
I think what Jan has done to Michael is so cruel. I know. That she didn't call him. And also in that scene, Jan is like, Michael, you don't know what I've been through. And he said, no, no, I don't. And I love Steve's delivery on that. I know.
我觉得简对迈克尔做的事太残忍了。我知道。她竟然没有打电话给他。而且在那场戏里，简说：迈克尔，你根本不知道我经历过什么。而他说：不，不，我不知道。我太喜欢史蒂夫对这句台词的演绎了。我知道。
I guess she feels bad and she lets him hold the baby, but it says the baby has to stay in the car seat. And then Michael has this very sweet talking head where he says he loves babies and he tries to pick them up and hold one every day. It just nourishes him. And then we see this really sweet montage of Michael and babies and the babies love him. They really do. Well, that's because it's Steve Carell is holding the babies. I know. I mean, not to say that they wouldn't have loved Michael, but Steve is a natural with kids. I know.
我猜她觉得有些内疚，于是让他抱了抱婴儿，但规定婴儿必须一直呆在汽车安全座椅里。然后迈克尔有一段非常温馨的访谈镜头，他说他超级喜欢婴儿，并且每天都试图去抱抱他们。这滋养了他的心灵。接着我们看到了迈克尔和婴儿们的一组极其温馨的蒙太奇镜头，而婴儿们也很喜欢他。他们真的很喜欢。嗯，那是因为抱婴儿的是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。我知道。我是说，倒不是说他们不会喜欢迈克尔，但史蒂夫对付小孩子简直天生有一手。我知道。
We had a fan question from Evan L and Stacey M. In the scenes where Michael is holding all the babies, were those hired actors or did the crew just go out and let people line up to have their baby held by Steve Carell. All of those babies were the children of our writers and our crew. So here is a list of the babies. At nine minutes, you have Baby on the Street. This is Emma Holland, daughter of our editor Dean Holland, and that is also Dean's wife, Tasha. At nine minutes, nine seconds, I'm calling this one Baby at the Bathroom. That baby is Theodore Grandy. The woman is Sage Grandy.
我们收到了来自埃文·L和斯黛西·M的粉丝提问：在迈克尔抱着所有那些婴儿的场景中，那些是请来的演员，还是剧组直接走到街上，让大家排队把自己的宝宝交给史蒂夫·卡瑞尔抱？所有这些婴儿其实都是我们编剧和剧组工作人员的孩子。所以这里有一份婴儿名单：在第9分钟时，有“街头婴儿”。这是艾玛·霍兰德（Emma Holland），我们的剪辑师迪恩·霍兰德（Dean Holland）的女儿，旁边那位也是迪恩的妻子塔莎（Tasha）。在第9分09秒时，我把这个叫做“洗手间婴儿”。那个宝宝是西奥多·格兰迪（Theodore Grandy）。旁边的女士是萨姬·格兰迪（Sage Grandy）。
And this is the son of our writer, Charlie Grandy. At 9 minutes 15 seconds, we have Double Baby. And that is our writer, Mike Schur's wife, J.J. Philbin and their baby, William, along with our camera operator, Mike Schur's wife, J.J. Philbin and their baby William, along with our camera operator, Matt Sohn's wife, Melissa, and their baby Devin. And the final baby at 9 minutes 17 seconds, that is Avery Farrell, the daughter of our writer, Anthony Farrell. The woman was a background performer, but that's Anthony loading the stroller into the car. So we had had kind of
这是我们的编剧查理·格兰迪（Charlie Grandy）的儿子。在第9分15秒时，我们看到了“双胞胎婴儿”。那是我们的编剧迈克·舒尔（Mike Schur）的妻子JJ·菲尔宾（J.J. Philbin）和他们的宝宝威廉（William），还有我们的摄像师马特·索恩（Matt Sohn）的妻子梅丽莎（Melissa）以及他们的宝宝德文（Devin）。最后一个是第9分17秒时的婴儿，那是埃弗里·法瑞尔（Avery Farrell），我们的编剧安东尼·法瑞尔（Anthony Farrell）的女儿。那个女人是个群演，不过正在把婴儿车装上车的是安东尼本人。所以我们当时
like a little mini baby boom on our set. All of these kids were around the same age. I texted with Dean. He said his daughter Emma is now 13 years old and she tells everybody that she's one of the babies on the office. And Angela, I know you get asked a lot about Isabel because she was right around the same age too. Yes, Isabel just had her 13th birthday. There was this baby boom and it was really fun for us to have our babies on set. And I get asked if she was in this episode and she wasn't.
相当于在片场迎来了小小的一波婴儿潮。所有这些孩子年龄都差不多。我跟迪恩发信息聊过，他说他的女儿艾玛现在已经13岁了，她逢人就说自己是《办公室》里的婴儿之一。而且安吉拉，我知道你经常被问到伊莎贝拉（Isabel）的事，因为她当时年龄也差不多。是的，伊莎贝拉刚刚过了13岁生日。当时正值婴儿潮，我们的宝宝们能一起在片场玩，对我们来说真的超级有趣。而且我经常被问到她有没有参演这一集，答案是没有。
And you know why? The day they filmed the scene with all the babies was my day off. Oh. And I wanted to be home with my baby, not bringing my baby to work. So I wasn't in it. And they said, don't worry, Angela.
你们知道为什么吗？他们拍摄所有婴儿那场戏的那天正好是我的休息日。哦。我当时只想留在家里陪我的宝宝，而不是把宝宝带到工作场所去。所以我就没演那场戏。他们当时说：别担心，安吉拉。
We're going to get Isabelle in there. And they did. She ended up having a very fun day on set years later at Cece's dance recital. I can't wait. I know. Well, Michael's going to try to make the best of it, OK? He is going to present Astrid to the office.
我们以后一定把伊莎贝拉安排进去。他们确实做到了。多年后，她在西西的舞蹈汇演那场戏里，在片场度过了非常欢乐的一天。我等不及了。我知道。好吧，迈克尔要尽量把事情做好，对吧？他要向办公室正式介绍阿斯特丽德。
And they're going to go into the conference room. Jenna, he does the Lion King and holds the car seat over his head. I know. I hope that was all fake baby day. That was fake baby and that was all scripted. Oh boy. Well, when we move into the conference room, Kevin is like, you know, the fact that the babies here kind of ruins the games. And Michael is like, no, it doesn't.
他们要走进会议室了。珍娜，他居然模仿《狮子王》把汽车安全座椅高高举过头顶。我知道。我希望那全都是在拍假婴儿的那天拍的。那是假婴儿，而且全都是剧本里写好的。天哪。嗯，当我们走进会议室时，凯文说：你知道的，婴儿出现在这里简直把游戏都给毁了。而迈克尔却说：不，才没有。
No, it doesn't. It kind of did. Well, you know, the theme is a baby shower and all the games are for an expecting mother. So it was really awkward. But there are a lot of scenes in this conference room baby shower that didn't make it. I'm going to share a few. The first one is Jenna, of the funniest things I have had to witness and we could not get through it. Kevin thinks he might be the sperm donor and the look on Jan's face is amazing. Sam, can you play that from the deleted scenes? Hey Jan, you went to a sperm bank? Yes, I did. I donated sperm.
不，才没有。其实真的挺毁气氛的。嗯，你知道的，主题是个迎婴派对，所有的游戏都是为准妈妈准备的。所以当时气氛非常尴尬。不过会议室里的这个迎婴派对有许多被删减掉的镜头。我来分享几个。第一个是，珍娜，这是我见过的最搞笑的事情之一，我们当时根本笑得停不下来。凯文觉得他自己可能是精子捐赠者，而简脸上的表情绝了。萨姆，你能从删减片段里播放一下那段吗？嘿，简，你去过精子库？是的，我去过。我捐过精。
Jan, you went to a sperm bank? Uh, yes. I did. I donated sperm. Oh. Ooh. Maybe I'm the father. Well, this is a highly exclusive establishment. Next to the IHOP? Well, I paid for an ideal specimen.
简，你去过精子库？额，是的。我去过。我捐过精。哦。噢。也许我是父亲呢。嗯，这是一个高度专营的机构。在国际煎饼屋（IHOP）旁边？嗯，我花钱买的是理想的标本。
Are you saying Kevin is not an ideal specimen? This is a wonderful shower, everyone. Thank you. I might have done it with Jan. It's not Kevin. We could not get through it. Whenever Brian said, you mean the one by IHOP? I just, every single time, because Melora's reaction as Jan was so good. And then, you
你是说凯文不是理想的标本？这是一个很棒的派对，大家。谢谢。说不定我和简发生过呢。根本不是凯文。我们当时根本拍不下去。每当布赖恩说：你是说IHOP旁边的那家吗？我真的，每一次都笑喷，因为梅洛拉作为简的反应实在是太精彩了。然后，
know, she says she paid for premium sperm, which we learned might've been Andierodic's. I love there are so many deleted scenes about who the father of Jan's baby is. We've got Andierodic, maybe Kevin. There's a lot of speculation that it's Hunter. Yes. And none of these scenes actually made it into the episodes. So what do you think about that? Do you think like if something didn't make it in,
你知道的，她说她花大钱买的是优质精子，我们后来了解到那可能是安迪·罗迪克（Andy Roddick）的。我喜欢关于谁才是简的孩子父亲的那些海量删减片段。我们有安迪·罗迪克的版本，也许是凯文的版本。还有很多猜测认为父亲是亨特（Hunter）。是的。而这些场景实际上都没有剪进正片里。所以你们对此怎么看？你们觉得如果某个内容没剪进去，
it counts or does it not count if it doesn't make it in the episode? So yeah, what is the canon, right? Yes, exactly. What is the canon of, exactly. Well, I guess it would have to be what aired, right? So then that would mean it's just a mystery. It's a mystery. She paid top dollar for it though. That's what we know. Yeah, that's all we know and all we'll ever truly know. And I think the one thing we also know is that it's not Michael's because he had to wear two condoms. We know that. Yeah, we know whose baby it's not. That's right. I got this cool letter from Kristen B.
它还算数吗？还是说如果没有剪进剧集里，它就不算正史（canon）？所以，什么是正史，对吧？是的，exactly。正史究竟是什么，对吧？嗯，我猜那只能是最终播出的内容，对吧？那也就是说这其实成了一个谜。这是一个谜。不过她确实为此花了巨资，这是我们知道的。是的，这就是我们所知道的全部，也是我们永远能真正确知的全部。我想我们唯一确知的一点是，这绝对不是迈克尔的孩子，因为他当时不得不戴两个安全套。我们知道这个。是的，我们知道这绝不是谁的孩子。没错。我收到了克里斯蒂安·B发来的一封超酷的来信。
She has a background catch and she said, The first time I watched this episode after having my son, I almost jumped out of my seat when I saw the pink donut pillow on Jan's chair at the baby shower. I had never noticed it prior to giving birth, but after I got one at the hospital myself, I just have to say this is amazing and 10-10 for attention to detail. That is a great background catch. I noticed it as well. I loved that detail. I did too. I don't know if you guys also noticed behind Jan's chair, there's a little table and on the table is a big bird stuffed animal. There is a deleted scene where Michael tells
她有一个背景穿帮发现，她说：“自我生完儿子后第一次看这一集时，当我看到迎婴派对上简的椅子上放着那个粉红色的甜甜圈坐垫时，我差点从座位上跳起来。我在生孩子之前从未注意到过它，但自从我在医院也拿到了一个同款之后，我只想说这太惊人了，细节满分。”这真是一个绝妙的背景发现。我也注意到了。我超喜欢这个细节。我也是。我不知道你们有没有注意到简的椅子后面还有一张小桌子，桌上放着一个大鸟（Big Bird）毛绒玩具。有一个删减片段是迈克尔告诉
Phyllis he wants storks. She said she couldn't get storks and he's like, look, I barely got Jan to even come today. This needs to be a big party. If you can't get a stork, I at least want big bird. And the best Phyllis could do is she got a big bird stuffed animal. least want Big Bird and the best Phyllis could do is she got a Big Bird stuffed animal. Wow. Yeah. Oh, that is so great. Well, the group gives Jan her gift. It's a stroller. I think this is a very nice gift. It's a very nice gift because it's a big ticket item, but she's already got a stroller. She has an orbit. That Oscar tells us costs $1,200. Yeah.
菲利斯他想要送子鸟（storks）。她说她弄不到送子鸟，然后迈克尔说：听着，我能把简劝来参加今天的派对就已经很勉强了。这必须是一场盛大的派对。如果你弄不到送子鸟，我至少要一个大鸟（Big Bird）。而菲利斯能做到的极限就是搞来了一个大鸟毛绒玩具。至少要大鸟，而菲利斯能做到的最好结果就是弄来了一个大鸟毛绒玩具。哇。是的。哦，太棒了。好吧，大家送给简她的礼物。是一辆婴儿车。我觉得这是一份非常棒的礼物。这是一份非常厚礼，因为这是一件大件昂贵商品，但她其实已经有一辆婴儿车了。她有一个奥比特（Orbit）婴儿车。
Hmm. Dwight is curious. He's like, I need to see how good this stroller really is. Yeah, he said his whole bomb shelter bunker thing that he built didn't even cost that much. And he needs to see what the stroller is made of, if it's going to cost that much. So yeah, he wheels the stroller out,
奥斯卡告诉我们价值1200美元。是的。嗯。德怀特很好奇。他说：我得看看这辆婴儿车到底有多好。是的，他说他自己建造的那个避难堡垒花费甚至都没那么多。他必须亲自检验一下这辆婴儿车是用什么材料做的，居然敢卖那么贵。所以，好吧，他把婴儿车推了出去，
and then Jan is going to sing to the baby. Oh, Jenna. How did you get through this? How did you get through it? It was like bite the inside of your cheek, don't make eye contact with anyone, and also at the same time, in total awe of Melora. Yes, who has an amazing singing voice and performs as a singer,
然后简要为宝宝唱歌。哦，珍娜。你是怎么挺过这一关的？你是怎么熬过来的？感觉就像是咬紧牙关，千万不要和任何人对视，同时又对梅洛拉佩服得五体投地。是的，她拥有一副惊人的歌喉，而且本身就是以歌手身份在表演，
guys. Yes, she has albums. Yes, she's an amazing singer. She just owned this moment so wholeheartedly. There is a scene, Jenna, that was in the script that we shot. I remember shooting it because the timing and everything in it was amazing. So Jan is singing, Son of a Preacher Man. She's belting it out. And Ryan comes in urgently to tell her something. She won't stop singing. And I printed out the script. Here, Jenna, just read right here.
伙计们。是的，她出过专辑。是的，她是个了不起的歌手。她全身心地掌控了这一刻。珍娜，剧本里其实还有一个我们拍过的场景。我记得当时拍过，因为里面的时机和一切都太棒了。简当时在唱《传道士之子》（Son of a Preacher Man）。她唱得荡气回肠。然后瑞安急匆匆地走进来告诉她某事。她却根本停不下来。我还把剧本打印出来了。来，珍娜，你就读这部分。
Okay, so I'm gonna be Ryan. Yeah. Okay. And you guys forgive my singing. I'm not a singer, okay? Okay. Was the son of a preacher man? Yes, he was.
好的，那我要演瑞安。好的。大家原谅我的歌声。我可不是歌手，好吗？好的。《传道士之子》？是的，他就是。
Hey, Jan. He was. Jan. Yes, he was. You parked in the handicap spot. Keys are in my purse. I'll just, I'll take them. Did I do good? You did great. Sorry to make you guys suffer through my singing. Melora was amazing. She never missed a beat. She sang where her keys were. It was amazing. I did a mini deep dive on Son of a Preacher Man. Did you really? Yes. I think we should take a break and when we come back, I'll tell you what I found. Okay.
嘿，简。他就是。简。是的，他就是。你把车停在残疾人车位了。钥匙在我的钱包里。我来，我去拿钥匙。我唱得好吗？你棒极了。抱歉让大家饱受我歌声的折磨。梅洛拉太惊艳了。她节奏从未出错。她一边唱着钥匙在哪儿一边把戏演完了。太厉害了。我对《传道士之子》做了一番小型深入研究。真的吗？是的。我觉得我们应该休息一下，等回来后，我再告诉你们我都发现了什么。好的。
All right. We are back and I'm going to start us off with a fan question from Yvette M and Alexandra S. Why was the song, Son of a Preacher Man, chosen for Jan to sing to her baby? I asked Aaron who picked the song and Aaron said he isn't sure if Mindy picked it per se, but she was pushing it. He said, I don't remember how exactly it came up in the writer's room, but the minute it was out there, Mindy was like, that's got to be it. That has got to be it. So I think we have Mindy to thank
好的，我们回来了。我要先分享一个来自伊薇特·M和亚历山德拉·S的粉丝提问：为什么会选择《传道士之子》这首歌作为简唱给宝宝听的歌？我问过埃林是谁选的这首歌，埃林说他不太确定是不是明迪本人选的，但确实是她在力推。他说：我不记得当时在编剧室里具体是怎么讨论的，但这首歌一被提出来，明迪就说：那就定这首了。这绝对得是这首。所以我想我们要感谢明迪
for that. I got curious about the song, so I did a little deep dive on it. Son of a Preacher Man was written by John Hurley and Ronnie Wilkins. It was recorded by Dusty Springfield in 1968 and her version is most popular. It's been covered many times by many artists. Here's what I found interesting. Apparently the rights to record the song were originally offered to Aretha Franklin. She was the daughter of a preacher, and the rumor
选择了这首歌。我对这首歌产生了好奇，于是做了一番深入研究。《传道士之子》由约翰·赫尔利（John Hurley）和罗尼·威尔金斯（Ronnie Wilkins）创作。它最初由达斯蒂·斯普林菲尔德（Dusty Springfield）于1968年录制，她的版本最为流行。这首歌后来被许多艺术家翻唱过多次。以下是我觉得有趣的地方：显然，这首歌的录制版权最初是提供给艾瑞莎·富兰克林（Aretha Franklin）的。她是传道士的女儿，而有传言
is that she turned it down because she worried that maybe it might be a little disrespectful. But she changed her mind. Oh! And she recorded a cover version of the song just one year later in 1969 for her album Soul Sister. I had to hear it. Sam, will isn't it? She always gives me chills. Dolly Parton also did a cover in 1996 for her album Treasures, and it is also a gem. Do you want to hear that one? Yes! I mean, I can listen to these women sing anything. They're legends, legends in our podcast today.
称她当时拒绝了，因为她担心这首歌可能会稍微有点不够尊重大体。但后来她改变了主意。哦！仅仅一年后的1969年，她就在自己的专辑《灵魂姐妹》（Soul Sister）中录制了一版这首歌的翻唱。我当时非听不可。萨姆，是不是很棒？她的歌声总是让我起鸡皮疙瘩。多莉·帕顿（Dolly Parton）也在1996年为她的专辑《珍宝》（Treasures）翻唱过这首歌，那同样是一块瑰宝。你们想听听那一版吗？想！我是说，这些传奇女歌手唱什么我都愿意听。她们是传奇，是我们今天播客里的传奇。
Do we need to hear Dusty's? I think we need to hear Dusty's. I mean, we have to hear Dusty's. It's Son of a Preacher Man Day today. I mean, I just want to hear all of them. I feel so embarrassed that I even attempted to sing it at all to recreate the scene with Ryan. I am so sorry. Ah!
我们需要听黛asty（Dusty）的版本吗？我觉得我们得听。我是说，我们必须听。今天是“传道人之子”日。我是说，我只是想听所有的版本。我甚至尝试唱它来重现和瑞安在一起的那个场景，现在想来我都觉得好尴尬。真的非常抱歉。啊！
Billy Ray was a preacher's son. And when his daddy would visit, he'd come along. When they gathered round and started talking, That's when Billy would take me a-walkin'. Here's what I have to say. Kudos to John Hurley and Ronnie Wilkins, because when you write a song that can be sung by all of these different people with their different spins on it and their different arrangements... And it still knocks your socks off every time. You have written a good song. Yep. One last thing I want to say about Son of a Preacher Man is that when Melora sang it, she improvised the snapping.
比利·雷是个传教士的儿子。每当他爸爸来访，他就会跟着一起来。当大家聚在一起开始聊天时，那就是比利带我去散步的时候。这是我想说的。向约翰·赫利（John Hurley）和罗尼·威尔金斯（Ronnie Wilkins）致敬，因为当你写出一首能被所有这些不同的人用他们不同的风格和编曲来演唱的歌时……而且每次听都依然让人惊艳。那你确实写了一首好歌。没错。关于《传道人之子》，我最后想说的是，梅洛拉（Melora）在唱这首歌时，即兴加入了打响指的动作。
And you know what? It about got me on the floor. We were so trying to suppress laughter that one more thing was like the tipping point, you know? Yes. And so as she's swaying and singing, when she just starts doing that snap, I was like, oh Lord, I'm not going to make it. I am not going to make it.
你知道吗？我差点笑翻在地。我们当时极力压抑着笑意，所以再来这么一点就像是压垮骆驼的最后一根稻草，你知道吗？是的。所以当她摇摆着唱歌并开始打响指时，我在想，哦天哪，我撑不下去了。我真的撑不下去了。
There are really great scripted talking heads of people reacting to it. And Stanley had a great one where he was like, I used to like that song. Well, Jim is going to try to describe it to Pam. She's at the laundromat and she can't hear anything he's saying. Why couldn't she just walk away from the machines, Jenna? You know what? Megan P would like to know the answer to that question as well.
里面有一些非常棒的剧本化访谈，人们对此做出反应。斯坦利（Stanley）有一个很棒的访谈，他说：“我以前挺喜欢这首歌的。”好吧，吉姆（Jim）试图向帕姆（Pam）描述这首歌。她在自助洗衣店，根本听不清他在说什么。简娜，她为什么不直接走开，离开那些机器呢？你知道吗？梅根·P（Megan P）也想知道这个问题的答案。
Megan, it's the first thing I thought. She hasn't talked to him all day. She finally has free time. Walk away from the machine. I'll tell you two things. Number one, right before this phone call, there was a bit of the scene that got clipped. Pam is with her friend at the laundromat, and they are together and they're talking about a class assignment, and she says, oh, just one second, I'm going to take this call. So maybe she felt like she couldn't walk away. But also in the script, there is a version where she does walk away from the machines. And the problem is not that the machines are loud. The problem is simply that Pam is not
梅根，这是我脑子里冒出的第一个想法。她一整天都没跟他说过话。她好不容易有了空闲时间。快从机器旁走开吧。我要告诉你两件事。第一，就在这通电话之前，场景里有一小段被剪掉了。帕姆和她的朋友在自助洗衣店里，她们在一起讨论课堂作业，然后她说，“哦，等一下，我要接个电话。”所以她可能觉得自已不能走开。但在剧本中，有一个版本是她确实走开了。问题不在于洗衣机太吵。问题单纯在于帕姆没有
understanding what's so bad about Jan singing to her baby. So it's another kind of like... Miscommunication. Like you had to be there kind of things. But they kept the loud laundry machine version in. I'll have you know location alert, the laundromat was Launderland on Sherman Way in North Hollywood, California. I like to throw these out there because there are these office tours where people go around and look at our locations. And so I thought, I don't know if you want to see where Pam did her laundry. That's where. Okay.
明白简对着婴儿唱歌有什么不好的。所以这又是另一种……沟通不畅。就像那种“你得在现场才能体会”的事情。但他们保留了洗衣机很吵的那个版本。顺便告诉大家一个拍摄地警报，这家自助洗衣店是加利福尼亚州北好莱坞谢尔曼大道（Sherman Way）上的朗德兰（Launderland）。我喜欢把这些说出来，因为有一些办公室巡礼，人们会到处参观并寻找我们的拍摄地点。所以我想，我不知道你们是不是想看看帕姆洗衣服的地方。就是那儿。好的。
So Pam has this talking head at the laundromat where she says that she's not frustrated. You know, they have these kind of days where they don't connect even when they're together and scranton. And then she discovers that she washed her lipstick and it got all over her green towel. You know, I recently washed Lee's wallet and car key. I remember this. You called me and you're like, I washed the keys to the car, his whole entire wallet. Whole wallet. Whole wallet. And now he couldn't find his wallet for days. He was like, where's my wallet? I can't find
所以帕姆在自助洗衣店里有一个访谈，她说她并不是很沮丧。你知道的，他们有时就是会有这样的一天，即使在一起也无法产生连接，就像在斯克兰顿那样。然后她发现她把口红洗了进去，整条绿毛巾上都是口红。你知道的，我最近洗了李（Lee）的钱包和车钥匙。我记得这个。你打电话给我说：“我把车钥匙全洗了，还有他整个钱包。”整个钱包。整个钱包。结果他找了好几天都找不到钱包。他说：“我的钱包呢？我找不到
my wallet. It was in the laundry basket. It was in his pocket in the laundry basket. And I didn't check the pockets. I threw in the laundry. I found it in the dryer. It went through a full wash cycle, a full dryer cycle. I said, babe, I found your wallet. Wait, did the credit cards, did it all get melted?
我的钱包了。”它就在洗衣篮里。就在洗衣篮的口袋里。而我没检查口袋。我就把它扔进了洗衣机。我在烘干机里找到了它。它经历了一次完整的洗涤循环，一次完整的烘干循环。我对他说：“宝贝，我找到你的钱包了。”等等，信用卡，全融化了吗？
Did he have to get everything new? Lady, his vaccination card was in his wallet. Oh no. All of his credit cards. He was like, oh my God, the vaccination card made it. It was a little frayed at the top. He went out, he bought some gas and the credit cards worked. Well, how about that?
他得把所有东西都换新的吗？天哪，他的疫苗接种卡就在钱包里。噢不。所有的信用卡。他说：“哦天哪，疫苗接种卡居然完好无损。”顶部有点磨损。他出门加了点油，信用卡居然还能用。好吧，你觉得呢？
So I don't know. I guess you didn't have it on high heat. No, I did dry on low. And the car key still works because it's one of those little like, quirk quirk, quirk quirk. No, I did dry on low. And the car key still works, because it's one of those little like, brr-brr, brr-brr. Yeah, it still works. While all of the singing is going on,
所以我不清楚。我猜你没用高温烘干。不，我是低温烘干的。而且车钥匙还能用，因为那是那种小小的，哔哔，哔哔。不，我是低温烘干的。车钥匙还能用，因为它是个那种小小的，哔哔，哔哔。对，它还能用。就在歌声进行的同时，
Dwight decides he's gonna put the stroller to the ultimate test. Yes, we had a fan question from Beth E, Rachel R, Amy F, and Julie G. How many of those strollers did you use for the scenes where Dwight tests its durability? This is why I was on the phone with Phil Shea for an hour yesterday. Well how many did they use? I'll tell you, it started with Phil Shea
德怀特（Dwight）决定对婴儿车进行终极测试。是的，我们收到了来自贝丝·E（Beth E）、瑞秋·R（Rachel R）、艾米·F（Amy F）和朱莉·G（Julie G）的粉丝提问。在德怀特测试婴儿车耐用性的那些场景中，你们到底用了多少辆婴儿车？这就是为什么我昨天和菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）通了一个小时的电话。那他们到底用了多少辆？我来告诉你，一切都始于菲尔·谢伊
doing a ton of research to find the perfect stroller for this episode. He said he and Greg had a long talk about how Jan was the kind of person who would have to have the fanciest stroller. In the script, it's written that the stroller is indestructible and he wanted to find something that would even look out of place in Scranton. So he went on a search for an indestructible luxury stroller and he found out about the Orbit baby stroller, which was kind of a startup stroller at the time. It launched in September of 2006, so just two years before this episode. It was invented by two dads, Brian White and Joseph High. I think it's High. Joseph, I'm sorry if I got that
做了大量的研究，为这一集寻找完美的婴儿车。他说他和格雷格（Greg）进行了长谈，讨论简是那种必须拥有最豪华婴儿车的人。剧本里写着这婴儿车是不可摧毁的，他想找一样在斯克兰顿看起来甚至有点格格不入的东西。所以他开始搜寻不可摧毁的豪华婴儿车，然后他发现了Orbit婴儿车，当时它算是一款初创公司的婴儿车。它于2006年9月推出，也就是这一集播出的两年前。它是由两位父亲布莱恩·怀特（Brian White）和约瑟夫·海（Joseph High）发明的。我觉得是海。约瑟夫，如果我记错了，请
wrong. And they made it because Brian had just become a dad. And he said that his back really hurt whenever he was trying to get the baby in and out of the car seat in the car. So in his garage, they made a wooden prototype. They studied all kinds of things, but they also sought to use green materials. I like these fellas. Yeah, and this car seat was cool because Phil said it looked kind of weird, but it also rotates 360 degrees. So Phil was like, it was so cool. Like if you want to get your baby out of the car and not remove the car seat, you can swivel it and then you can get your baby out of the car really easy. Well, Jenna, you know Phil Shea had a few extra orbits left over and I was a new mom on set and he always was looking out for us and he said,
原谅我。他们制造它是是因为布莱恩刚当上爸爸。他说每当他试图把婴儿放进或抱出车里的安全座椅时，他的腰真的非常痛。于是在他的车库里，他们制作了一个木制原型。他们研究了各种各样的东西，但他们也力求使用环保材料。我喜欢这两个小伙子。是的，这款安全座椅很酷，因为菲尔说它看起来有点奇怪，但它还能360度旋转。所以菲尔当时就觉得，这太酷了。如果你想把宝宝从车里抱出来又不想拆卸安全座椅，你可以旋转它，然后就能非常轻松地把宝宝抱出来了。好吧，詹娜，你知道菲尔·谢伊还多留了几辆Orbit婴儿车，而我当时是片场的新手妈妈，他总是很关照我们，他对我说：
Ange, do you want one of these orbit strollers? They're pretty amazing. And I said, yeah. And that was my favorite thing about it too, what you just said. You could pivot and it would lock into place. So if you swiveled it, it could face left, right, front, back, and it would lock into place. Not only was it great when you got your baby out of the car seat, what I loved is you could attach it to the stroller. And let's say you're on a walk and the sun is kind of beating down and you don't want
“安吉，你想要一辆这种Orbit婴儿车吗？它们挺神奇的。”我说：“好啊。”这也是我最喜欢它的地方，正如你刚刚所说的那样。你可以旋转它，它会卡入到位。所以如果你转动它，它可以面向左、右、前、后，并且会卡入固定。不仅在你把宝宝从安全座椅抱出来时很好用，我最喜欢的是你可以把它装到婴儿车车架上。比方说你在散步，太阳有点大，你又不想
to put the little flap over your baby because your baby wants to be able to see where you're going, you could just pivot so then the baby could look at everything on the right side of the street or everything on the left side or look at you. It was so great. I love that Phil gave you a stroller and that he gave you a chair from Workbus. I know. Do you have any more things? I'm sure I do. Maybe your memory will be jogged as we go along. As we go through the episodes. Do you have any more things? I'm sure I do.
把婴儿车的小遮阳蓬拉下来，因为宝宝想看清你们前行的方向，你只需要转动一下，宝宝就能看到街道右侧的一切，或者左侧的一切，或者看着你。这真是太棒了。我很高兴菲尔送了你一辆婴儿车，他还送了你一把来自《工作巴士》的椅子。我知道。你还有别的东西吗？我确信我有的。也许随着我们的深入，你的记忆会被唤醒。随着我们回顾这些剧集。你还有别的东西吗？我确信我有的。
Maybe your memory will be jogged as we go along. As we go through the episodes. Well, Phil said that he called Brian on the phone, and he was like, listen, I've researched your stroller, and I want to put it on the television show, The Office. And he told him the storyline, and Brian agreed to send us 10 strollers. And then Brian flew out and watched the taping.
也许随着我们的深入，你的记忆会被唤醒。随着我们回顾这些剧集。好吧，菲尔说他给布莱恩打了个电话，他说：“听着，我研究了你们的婴儿车，我想把它放到电视剧《办公室》里。”他把剧情告诉了布莱恩，布莱恩同意给我们寄10辆婴儿车。然后布莱恩还飞过来观看了拍摄。
Phil also said the stroller really was indestructible. He's not kidding. There are so many deleted scenes of Rain as Dwight doing things to that stroller. Oh yeah. And the stroller just keeps on trekking. There's way more. Phil told me that one of his favorite things to do was to reach out to these smaller companies that
菲尔还说这款婴儿车确实是不可摧毁的。他可没开玩笑。有很多删除片段都是雷恩（Rain）饰演的德怀特对那辆婴儿车做出各种举动。哦，是的。而且婴儿车依然坚挺地继续运转。还有更多呢。菲尔告诉我，他最喜欢做的事情之一就是联系那些
didn't normally do national advertising and feature their products on the show or collaborate with them. And he said, another one of the reasons that you saw all of the local foods or the local sodas on The Office was because one of our characters is eating like Lay's potato chips. That could be a conflict with maybe another big national potato chip brand that would
通常不做全国广告的小公司，并在节目中展示他们的产品或与他们合作。他说，你在《办公室》里看到的所有地方特色食品或地方汽水的原因之一，是因为其中一个角色在吃乐事薯片。这可能会与另一个大型全国薯片品牌产生冲突，因为对方可能会在我们的节目播出期间投放全国性的商业广告，所以我们是不被允许的。因此，他的选择要么是在乐事上面贴标，要么做一个假的袋子。
have a national commercial running during our show, so we weren't allowed. So his choice was he could tape over Lay's or create a fakey bag. Fakey chip bag. Right. He said, but what he liked to do was feature products, local products like a Hearst chip. A smaller company. That is not going to be in competition for these national spots. And that's another way that he focused in on the orbit. He would try to find these companies that could be approved.
假的薯片袋。对的。他说，但他喜欢做的是展示产品，比如赫斯特（Hearst）薯片这样的本地产品。一家规模较小的公司。这不会与这些全国性的广告位构成竞争。这也是他关注Orbit的另一种方式。他会试图寻找那些能够获得批准的公司。
Well, I love that because you you know we love supporting small business. Yeah, well the Orbit stroller is still available and it is now a big business. I saw online you can get one at Nordstrom. Well, Gianna's done singing, she's pooped out. I mean, all that singing is gonna tire you out. Yeah, she wants to take a nap. She gives the baby to Michael.
嗯，我很喜欢这样，因为你知道我们热爱支持小企业。是的，嗯，Orbit婴儿车现在仍然有售，而且它现在已经是一家大企业了。我在网上看到你在诺德斯特龙（Nordstrom）就能买到。好了，吉娜唱完了，她累瘫了。我是说，唱这么多歌会把你累坏的。是的，她想睡个午觉。她把婴儿交给了迈克尔。
And she says, when I wake up, I wanna talk to you about Astrid And she says, when I wake up, I want to talk to you about Astrid's 529, which I looked up. It's like a savings plan for college. Yeah. So what Michael has to go to all the birthing classes, but he doesn't get to be there for the birth of the baby. And now he's going to contribute to the college fund. That's what it sounds like. Jan needs to go bye bye. I agree. Well, Michael only holds the baby for a short time. He's not feeling
然后她说：“等我醒了，我想跟你谈谈阿斯特丽德（Astrid）的……”她还说：“等我醒了，我想跟你谈谈阿斯特丽德的529计划。”我查了一下。这就像是一个大学储蓄计划。是的。所以迈克尔不得不去上所有的生育课程，但他却无法出席孩子的出生。现在他还要给大学基金捐款。听起来就是这样。简需要说拜拜了。我同意。好吧，迈克尔只抱了孩子一会儿。他并没有感觉到
that connection and he gives the baby to Phyllis. Yeah. First, Michael has to go to the warehouse. He needs some advice from Darryl. We had a fan question from Ethan B. Did Steve improvise the moment when he asks if he can hold Darryl. They get on this runner where Daryl's like, do you want to hold this? Do you want to hold that and see if you have a connection? Do you want to hold me? No, you guys, that was in the script. That whole scene was scripted just like that. Well, Jan is still sleeping in the deleted scenes. She's like snoring and everyone's looking at her. She's covered herself with the plastic tablecloth from the shower and she wakes up and has a pretty amazing exchange with Holly.
那种连接，于是他把孩子交给了菲利斯。是的。首先，迈克尔必须去仓库。他需要向达里尔（Darryl）征求一些建议。我们收到了来自伊森·B（Ethan B）的粉丝提问。当史蒂夫（Steve）问他是否可以抱抱达里尔时，那是他即兴发挥的吗？他们开始了一个梗，达里尔说：“你想抱这个吗？你想抱那个，看看你们有没有连接吗？你想抱我吗？”不，伙计们，那是剧本里写好的。整场戏都是那样按剧本拍的。嗯，在删除片段中，简还在睡觉。她打着呼噜，每个人都在看着她。她用婴儿 shower（迎婴派对）上的塑料桌布把自己盖了起来，然后她醒了过来，和霍莉（Holly）有了一段非常精彩的对话。
Where she realizes what we have realized, which is that Holly has a little bit of Michael Scott in her. Yeah. She's making some real Michael Scott jokes here. Yeah. And Jana's like, oh, I get it, funny. But Astrid is now with Angela and Andy. I love the scene so much. Angela, please tell me everything about putting all these vegetables on this baby. All right, they had the table completely laid out. They had it all staged. They had the mom with the baby in the wings
在这里，她意识到了我们已经意识到的事情，那就是霍莉身上有一点迈克尔·斯科特的影子。是的。她在这里开了一些非常具有迈克尔·斯科特风格的玩笑。是的。然后简的反应是：“哦，我懂了，真搞笑。”但阿斯特丽德现在和安吉拉以及安迪在一起。我太喜欢这个场景了。安吉拉，请把把这些蔬菜摆在这个婴儿身上的所有细节都告诉我。好的，他们把桌子完全布置好了。他们把一切都摆拍好了。他们让妈妈带着婴儿在侧翼
standing right there. And literally right before action, the mom put the baby down. And then I just put that big giant fake piece of lettuce on the baby. It was really hard for me because I was a new mom and I was just like, okay, I just want to do this so fast. I want to do the scene so quickly. And then it was so hard for me as a mom to not really connect with the baby at all. And just say like, I needed to look up here.
就站在那里。字面意义上就在喊“action”之前，妈妈把婴儿放了下来。然后我把那块巨大无比的假生菜叶子放到了婴儿身上。这对我来说真的很难，因为我当时是一个新手妈妈，我心里想的是，好吧，我只想快点把这个做完。我想快点拍完这场戏。作为一个妈妈，很难做到完全不和婴儿产生任何连接，这对我来说太难了。我当时只想说：“我需要看向这里。”
Make it look up here. Yes. But it's such a window into Angela. You know, she was a pageant baby. She dresses up her cats. Yes. I feel like her kids are going to be dressed up a lot for all kinds of photos. And Andy is on board.
让它看向这里。是的。但这简直是了解安吉拉的一扇窗户。你知道的，她以前是个选美宝宝。她给她的猫咪们盛装打扮。是的。我觉得她的孩子们以后也会为了各种各样的照片而被精心打扮一番。而且安迪也很赞同。
I always imagined that Angela dressed Philip in like the little knee socks and shorts and suspenders with the little Peter Pan collar that you always see little Prince George wearing. That's how I imagined Philip dresses. Oh yeah. And I also imagined that Angela had like a little sailor suit for him. For sure. With a sailor hat. A hundred percent. All of that.
我一直想象着安吉拉给菲利普（Philip）穿那种小及膝袜、短裤、背带裤，配上你在小乔治王子身上总能看到的那种小彼得潘领。这就是我想象中菲利普的穿衣风格。哦，是的。而且我还想象安吉拉给他准备了一套小小水手服。肯定的。带着水手帽。百分之百。所有这些。
Yes. Jan comes in as Andy and Angela are having their Ann Getty's moment creating this baby salad photo and she is not happy. No, she's irritated and she wants to go. She's done. She's done. She finds Michael in the kitchen and she's ready to go and Michael insults Holly again. I guess we've failed to mention
是的。就在安迪和安吉拉享受他们的安妮·盖茨（Anne Geddes）时刻、创作这幅婴儿沙拉照片时，简进来了，她很不高兴。不，她很烦躁，她想走了。她受够了。她受够了。她在厨房里找到了迈克尔，她准备走了，而迈克尔又一次侮辱了霍莉。我想我们漏掉了
that throughout this whole episode, every time Michael, Holly and Jan are together, Michael just keeps insulting her. When Holly was gonna go into the conference room, he's like, ugh, HR. Now he says she smells like rotten tomatoes. And dirt. And dirt.
这样一点，在整整这一集里，每当迈克尔、霍莉和简聚在一起时，迈克尔就不停地侮辱她。当霍莉要走进会议室时，他说：“呃，人事部。”现在他说她闻起来像烂番茄。还有泥土。还有泥土。
She smells like tomatoes and dirt. Yeah. And you know what smells like tomatoes and dirt. Yeah. And you know what? Jan sees all of it. Jan knows what Michael's doing. And he walks her out to the car. And as she's putting the baby in the car seat, she turns around. She's like, there is one more thing you could do for me.
她闻起来像西红柿和泥土。是的。你知道什么闻起来像西红柿和泥土。是的。而且你知道吗？简把这一切都看在眼里。简知道迈克尔在做什么。他送她走到车前。当她把婴儿放进安全座椅时，她转过身来。她说：“你还能为我做最后一件事情。”
And he's like, what? And she says, don't date Holly. Yeah. And he's like, why would I hate her? Why would I? You know, and he clearly likes her. Yeah. And he's like, why would I hate her? Why would I, you know, and he clearly likes her. Yeah. Jan leaves.
他问：“什么事？”她说：“不要和霍莉约会。”是的。他问：“我为什么要恨她？我为什么要……”你知道的，他明显很喜欢她。是的。他问：“我为什么要恨她？我为什么要……”你知道的，他明显很喜欢她。是的。简离开了。
She leaves the stroller that was gifted to her. I know. So tacky. So tacky. Tacky Jan. What was the point of the baby shower? That she could get a nap and maybe get some money out of Michael for a college fund.
她把送给她的婴儿车留下了。我知道。太俗气了。太俗气了。俗气的简。举办迎婴派对的意义何在？就是为了能睡个午觉，也许还能从迈克尔那里弄点钱作为大学基金。
That's what it was. Yeah. Well, Michael is going to go upstairs. And he finds Holly, and she says, are you going to still be mean to me? And he just gives her a hug. It's the warmest, most intimate hug. It's so intimate.
事情就是这样。嗯，迈克尔要上楼去了。他找到了霍莉，她问：“你以后还会对我那么刻薄吗？”他只是给了她一个拥抱。那是极其温暖、极其亲密的拥抱。太亲密了。
Amy Ryan is so great. Her eyes just fill with tears. And then Michael has this talking head where he says he didn't feel much when he held Astrid, but he got a good feeling when he held Holly. He asked her out on a date. A real official date. She says yes. She sure does. So we're ending with a little love connection there. But now Jim and Pam are both trying to call each other at the same time and they miss each other. They both go to voicemail at the same time. And I remember Greg talking to me about this scene. I just loved this idea that we're going to hear each side of their voicemail message and you're going to see they
艾米·瑞安（Amy Ryan）演得太棒了。她的眼眶里充满了泪水。然后迈克尔有一个访谈，他说他在抱阿斯特丽德时并没有什么特别的感觉，但当他抱霍莉时，他有一种很好的感觉。他约她出去约会。一次真正官方的约会。她答应了。她当然答应了。所以我们以一点浪漫的连接结束了这一段。但现在吉姆和帕姆都在试图同时给对方打电话，结果他们错过了彼此。他们同时转入了语音信箱。我还记得格雷格跟我谈起这个场景时的情景。我太喜欢这个创意了，我们要听到他们各自语音信箱留言的一半，然后你会发现他们
really are connected. They both recall this same story about the time that, you know, some man came into the laundromat and Jim had to save Pam and then they bought a washer dryer. They're recalling this same event and at the end they both say, I guess this was just one of those days. I miss you. I wish you were home. Yeah. Aaron shared with me that he was just so curious how this scene would turn out because you guys filmed it in two different locations. You didn't have the other person there.
真的是心意相通。他们都回忆起同一件往事，当时某个男人来到自助洗衣店，吉姆不得不拯救帕姆，然后他们买了一台洗衣机烘干机。他们回忆着同一件事，最后他们都说：“我想今天就是那种日子吧。我想你。我希望你在家。”是的。亚伦（Aaron）跟我分享说，他当时非常好奇这个场景最终会呈现出什么效果，因为你们是在两个不同的地点拍摄的。你们身边并没有对方。
No, I couldn't hear John. It was like I was really leaving a message. Yeah. And so you guys were just in this vacuum separate. And then in editing, they were going in this vacuum separate and then in editing they were going to find the moment and create it and he just sort of marveled at how the whole thing came together and just so perfectly. Yes, well I had to really imagine in my head as an actor that I was just leaving a message so in the script I could see how our dialogue was gonna alternate and sync up. But I put that out of my mind and I just did my half
对，我听不到约翰的声音。那感觉就像我真的在留言一样。是的。所以你们当时处于一种真空隔离状态。然后在剪辑的时候，他们要在这种隔离中找到合适的时刻并将其构建起来，他对整件事情是如何组合在一起且如此完美感到惊叹。是的，作为演员，我在脑海中必须真正想象我只是在留言，所以在剧本中我能看出我们的对话将如何交替并同步。但我把这抛诸脑后，我只是完成了我的一半
without thinking of John's lines in my head at all. And we filmed it like a monologue. Yeah, well, I loved it. I thought it was really sweet. And it also made me a little sad because you can tell the distance is starting to take a toll. Yeah.
而完全没有在脑海中去想约翰的台词。我们把它拍得就像一段独白。是的，嗯，我很喜欢。我觉得它真的很温馨。这也让我感到有点悲伤，因为你能看出距离开始产生影响了。是的。
Well, that ends the episode, but Angela, I just realized I skipped a fan question. Okay. And I don't want to leave Evan L hanging. Okay, Evan. Evan wrote in to say, at 17 minutes 30 seconds, was that really rain driving around with the stroller tied to the back of the car or was that a stunt driver? Well, we had a stunt driver. His name was Sean Crowder. We also had a stunt coordinator named Wally Crowder. And so Sean did the driving parts. Now you know, there were some shots of rain inside the car, but the other stuff that was a stunt driver.
好了，这一集到此结束，但是安吉拉，我刚刚意识到我漏掉了一个粉丝提问。好的。我可不想让埃文·L（Evan L）悬着。好吧，埃文。埃文写信来问：“在17分30秒时，真的是雷恩开着车、后面还绑着婴儿车到处跑，还是那是特技替身演员？”嗯，我们确实有一个特技替身演员。他的名字叫肖恩·克劳德（Sean Crowder）。我们还有一个特技统筹叫沃利·克劳德（Wally Crowder）。所以驾驶部分是由肖恩完成的。现在你们知道了，有些雷恩在车内的镜头，但其他的那些就是特技演员了。
Yes, we would often do the driving that was just sort of like where you pull up and stop. But then if there was like aggressive driving, that's when the stunt driver would take over. Well, I loved this episode. I thought it was so good and layered with so much heartfelt stuff. And before we say goodbye, I have a little bit of trivia for you.
是的，我们经常会拍一些开车镜头，那种只是把车开过来然后停下的。但如果有那种激进驾驶，那就要由特技演员接手了。嗯，我很喜欢这一集。我觉得它非常棒，充满了真挚感人的细节。在我们说再见之前，我有一点冷知识要考考你。
Okay. According to babycenter.com, here are the top girl and boy names in 2008. Oh, from when we did this episode. That's right. Any guesses for the girl? Emma. Yes!
好的。根据babycenter.com的数据，以下是2008年最受欢迎的女孩和男孩名字。哦，也就是我们拍这一集的时候。没错。猜猜女孩的名字是什么？艾玛。是的！
Ah! You got it! I was thinking maybe because of the friends baby. Yes, Rachel had Emma. Really put that name on the map. Guess what the boy name was. I guessed Emma for the girl, like you, but I did not. Guess what the boy name was. I guessed Emma for the girl like you, but I did not guess right for the boy name.
啊！被你猜中了！我猜可能是因为《老友记》里的那个宝宝。是的，瑞秋生了艾玛。真的让这个名字名声大噪了。猜猜男孩的名字是什么？我跟你一样猜了女孩叫艾玛，但我没有……猜猜男孩的名字是什么？我跟你一样猜了女孩叫艾玛，但男孩的名字我没猜对。
Liam. Aiden. Aiden. Aiden was the top boy name. Was that from Sex and the City? I don't know. I guessed Jack. Okay.
利亚姆（Liam）。艾登（Aiden）。艾登。艾登是最受欢迎的男孩名字。那是来自《欲望都市》吗？我不知道。我猜的是杰克。好吧。
He was in the top five, but Aiden and Emma. Well, there it is. You've learned some new baby showers, Aiden and Emma. Well, there it is. You've learned some new baby showers, the Sip and See, M&Ms are still printing names. Yeah, and the Orbit Stroller's actually really good. And Emma and Aiden, 2008 babies, where are you now? I would love it if an Emma and Aiden got married. Oh, well that was Baby Shower.
他在前五名里，但艾登和艾玛。好了，就是这样。你们学到了一些关于新婴儿派对的知识，比如“Sip and See”（婴儿见面会），M&M豆现在还在印名字呢。是的，而且Orbit婴儿车其实真的很好。还有艾玛和艾登，2008年出生的宝宝们，你们现在在哪里？如果有叫艾玛和艾登的人结婚了，我可太喜欢了。好吧，这就是《婴儿派对》。
We'll see you next week. Bye, you guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwool, Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fischer. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubako.
我们下周见。拜拜，伙计们。感谢收听“办公室女士”。《办公室女士》由Earwool、詹娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金斯利（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔（Cody Fischer）担任执行制作人。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer）。我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科（Ainsley Bubako）。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《橡胶树》（Rubber Tree）。想要收听无广告版本的“办公室女士”，请访问StitcherPremium.com。想要免费试用一个月的Stitcher Premium，请使用代码OFFICE。这一集目前还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。